18 à 15 heures il n'y a pas d'opposition
à ce changement il en est ainsi décidé
l'ordre du jour appelle une déclaration
du gouvernement suivie d'un débat en
application de l'article 53 de la
constitution
sur le bilan de la présidence française
de l'union européenne
la parole est à madame catherine colonna
ministre l'europe et les affaires
étrangères à qui nous souhaitons la
bienvenue
monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs le
président de la république et la
première ministre m'ont fait un immense
honneur en accordant leur confiance
alors que je m'exprime pour la première
fois devant vous dans cet hémicycle je
veux vous assurer que je mesure
pleinement la responsabilité qui est la
mienne tout comme la secrétaire d'état
qui est à mes côtés
laurence boone je me suis vous assurer
que je souhaite associer pleinement le
parlement à l'action de mon ministère en
vous informant régulièrement de nos
travaux en débattant avec vous comme
nous le faisons aujourd'hui en vous
rendant compte de nos résultats et de
l'action de la diplomatie que je porte
sous l'autorité du président de la
république et de la première ministre je
n'aurais dans mon action qu un seul
impératif est qu'une seule boussole agir
au service des français
car alors que les ordres du monde et les
crises à répétition ne cesse d'affecter
de plus en plus leur quotidien je veux
porter une politique étrangère qui
contribue à apporter des réponses à
leurs préoccupations et voilà l'esprit
dans lequel j'entends travailler en tant
que ministre de l'europe et des affaires
étrangères je tenais à vous le dire
d'emblée et à vous le dire aussi
clairement que je viens de le faire
avant de presser comme vous me invités
avec vos le bilan de six mois de
présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne
je me réjouis beaucoup du débat sur ses
six mois de présidence française parce
que pour moi parler d'europe
c'est parler de notre souveraineté de
nos valeurs de notre avenir de notre
capacité à garder en tant que français
et en tant qu'européens notre destin en
main et donc pour le dire autrement à
rester les auteurs de notre histoire
collective que personne d'autre ne doit
venir écrire à notre place
nommé ministre terme d'un parcours qui
m'a entre autres emmenés de rome où fut
traité ou su signer le traité fondateur
du 25 mars 1957 à londres qui a fait le
choix de quitter l'union européenne un
choix que nous devons respecter mais que
nous regrettons je sais l'importance
capitale pour l'avenir de nos nations et
de nos peuples européens de ce projet
politique majeur qu'est l'europe ce
projet politique majeur qu'est l'europe
dans ce contexte je suis
particulièrement fier de pouvoir
affirmer que les résultats de ce
semestre français à la tête de l'europe
sont des résultats historiques
historique par leur portée mais
historique d'abord en raison des
circonstances inédite dans lesquelles
s'est déroulée cette présidence je pense
bien sûr à la guerre déclenchée par la
russie en ukraine au mépris du droit
international
de ses propres engagements de la
souveraineté de l'ukraine et de la
sécurité notre continent
ce choix funestes d'une agression le 24
février signe le retour de la guerre sur
notre continent et il a bien sûr
profondément marqué notre présidence
mais nous avons su répondre
collectivement en tant qu'européens et
c'était notre responsabilité de
présidence française que de réussir seul
à y répondre collectivement sans pour
autant mais je vais y revenir perdre le
cap de ce que nous avions décidé de
faire
nous allons donc poursuivre l' agenda
ambitieux que nous nous étions fixés en
amont de ces événements
ainsi au bout de six mois de présidence
je crois pouvoir dire que l'europe de
juillet 2022 n'est plus celle de
décembre 2021 elle est plus forte plus
souveraine et plus unis c'est bien sûr
le fruit des travaux de fond que nous
avons menée c'est également les faits d
urgence que nous avons eues à gérer
c'est le premier volet notre action sur
lequel je veux insister la réponse
immédiate à la guerre en ukraine que
vladimir poutine a pris la
responsabilité de déclencher le 24
février dernier aux portes de notre
union
l'europe n'était sans doute pas préparé
à affronter une mise en cause aussi
brutale de l'ordre international et de
ses propres intérêts stratégiques
pourtant elle a su réagir avec force et
unités à une crise qu'elle a tout fait
pour désamorcer
c'est ainsi l'honneur de notre pays
d'avoir pu mobiliser ses parts r
européens et internationaux pour y faire
face nous l'avons fait à titre national
en prenant toutes nos responsabilités
pour soutenir l'ukraine dans cette
guerre qu'elle doit gagner il va sans
avenir mais aussi d'une autre c'est une
nécessité pour que l'europe retrouve la
paix une nécessité pour que les
principes sur lesquels nous avons bâti
notre sécurité collective depuis la fin
de la seconde guerre mondiale soit
respecté
mais nous l'avons fait également dans
notre rôle de présidence
à l'initiative de la france l'europe
s'est en effet élevé à la hauteur des
enjeux en trois mois tout d'abord elle a
pris à l'encontre de la russie une série
de sanctions sans précédent au service
d'un objectif clair faire comprendre à
la russie qu'elle a choisi une impasse
et asphyxié le financement de son effort
de guerre
alors on a souvent coutume de reprocher
à l'union européenne sa lenteur ou son
manque de réactivité
or en moins de 48 heures le premier
paquet de sanctions étaient adoptées à
l'unanimité des vingt-sept et notre main
n'a jamais tremblé par la suite ce qui a
permis d'adopter tous les autres paquets
de sanctions qu'elle soit individuelle
financières ou commerciales
nous en sommes aujourd'hui vous le savez
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs à
six paquets et nous maintiendrons la
pression autant que nécessaire nous la
renforceront si cela est nécessaire
les européens ont aussi brisé ce qui
était jusqu'ici un tabou majeur en
europe parce qu'il le fallait en
décidant de financer des armements y
compris des armements les taux ces
armements dans l'ukraine a besoin pour
se défendre
et là aussi n'a pas fallu attendre
longtemps car dès le dimanche 27 février
cette décision était prise ce jour-là
les européens ont activé
le mécanisme la facilité européenne de
paix le mécanisme qui permet
de dégager des ressources à cette fin
est le message de l'europe ce jour là
était également très clair le temps de
l'innocence stratégique est révolu
l'europe est prête à faire face et elle
sait faire face
les pays européens ont également été au
rendez vous de la solidarité de
fraternité en accueillant les millions
d'ukrainiens et d'ukrainiens chassés par
le conflit à qui a été accordé
l'autorisation de venir se protéger dans
un pays de l'union en mai déficient de
droit très concret le droit au logement
au travail à la scolarisation des
enfants aux prestations de santé
nous avons pour cela utilisé pour la
première fois une directive qui datait
de 2001 permettant d'accorder ce qu'on
appelle la protection temporaire à ces
personnes déplacées et réfugiées
nous avons également mis en place un
très vaste de pont logistique pour
apporter à l'ukraine l'aide humanitaire
dont elle a besoin et nous avons vous le
savez également appuyé la moldavie
voisine qui est directement touchée par
les conséquences du conflit
nous avons faim doter l'union européenne
des moyens de collecter des preuves des
exactions et des crimes commis par
l'armée russe en ukraine en renforçant
le mandat dure juste parce qu'il ne
saurait y avoir d'impunité pour les
crimes de guerre
ce travail indispensable est venu en
complément de l'engagement des états qui
comme le nôtre ont soutenu et
soutiennent encore le travail des
autorités judiciaires ukrainienne et de
la cour pénale internationale
tance inédite et tragiques ont confirmé
à la fois la pertinence et l'urgence de
l'agenda de souveraineté dont le
président de la république avait donné
l'impulsion dès 2017 dans l'amphithéâtre
de la sorbonne et qui a constitué le fil
d'ariane de toute notre présidence c'est
le deuxième volet de cette présidence
française du conseil de l'union
européenne qui s'est attaché à tirer
toutes les conséquences de la guerre en
ukraine pour continuer et poursuivre le
renforcement de notre souveraineté et
contribuer ainsi à consolider
l'indépendance la sécurité et la
stabilité de l'europe
quelques mots à ce sujet au sommet de
versailles en mars dernier l'europe
affirmé sa volonté de rester maître de
son destin c'est à dire pleinement libre
de ses choix libre de ses choix
énergétiques
c'est l'ambition qui sous-tend la
décision prise par les chefs d'état ou
de gouvernement européens de sortir
rapidement de notre dépendance au
pétrole et il le faudra également au gaz
russe la france pour sa part je n'ai pas
besoin de souligner a toujours considéré
son indépendance énergétique comme
essentielle à sa souveraineté et ne peut
que se féliciter des choix qu'elle avait
fait dans le passé
libre de ses choix économiques aussi la
politique industrielle européenne ne se
réduit plus aujourd'hui au droit de la
concurrence avec des programmes
paneuropéen dans le domaine de la santé
de l'hydrogène ou encore des semi
conducteurs
nous bâtissons notre indépendance dans
des domaines qui sont des domaines
cruciaux pour notre avenir
du fait des crises du fait de ces crises
qui parfois nous réveille et qui
souligne les vulnérabilités qui étaient
les nôtres et nous engage à réagir une
prise de conscience se fait chaque jour
un peu plus en europe l'europe ne peut
pas être un grand marché un grand marché
de consommateurs qui achèteraient des
produits fabriqués ailleurs si l'on veut
être indépendant il faut aussi être
capable de produire soi-même en
particulier dans les secteurs critiques
mais pas seulement je pense que chacun
se sou bien au début de la pandémie de
lakovic 19 des difficultés qui étaient
les nôtres à nous procurer ne serait-ce
que masquer ou gels hydro alcooliques
au sommet de versailles est donc
toujours au mois de mars dernier
l'europe s'est mise à parler le langage
de la puissance c'est la condition de
notre sécurité collective
comment en décidant de remédier au sous
investissement dans les capacités
collectives individuelles de défense des
européens en se dotant d'une boussole
stratégique qui est un véritable livre
blanc de la sécurité de la défense
européenne et qui vaut pour les 10 ans
qui viennent elle a pu être adopté par
le conseil européen des 24 et 25 mars
dernier et elle fixe des objectifs très
concret pour que l'union puissent
conduire plus facilement des opérations
plus agile qu'elle renforce sa
résilience qu'elle investisse davantage
encore dans sa défense et améliore
encore sa coopération avec l'otan
par ailleurs au conseil européen des 23
et 24 juin
l'union s'est affirmée comme une
puissance de stabilité sur le continent
il faut mesurer je crois que l'histoire
permettra de le voir clairement le
caractère
véritablement historique qu'a été la
décision prise par le conseil européen à
l'unanimité d'octroyer à l'ukraine et à
la moldavie le statut de candidat à
l'union européenne
cette décision du conseil européen avait
été préparée notamment par le
déplacement à kiev le 16 juin du
président de la république avec le
chancelier allemand schulz le président
du conseil italien draghi et le
président romain ioannis
déplacements effectués à la veille de la
vie que devait rendre la commission sur
les demandes de ces pays et des
placements qui a certainement contribué
à forger le consensus au conseil
européen
le choix fait par notre union a été
d'envoyer à l'ukraine un message de
solidarité
vital bourrel comme la moldavie dont on
sait qu'elle est fragile est exposée
mais c'est aussi je voudrais le
souligner devant vous notre intérêt
stratégique car il n'y a plus de demi
mesure possible dès lors que la russie
avait choisi de se couper des principes
du droit international et de s'isoler
pour autant une fois ce statut de
candidat reconnu nous le savons tous la
perspective d'adhésion ne répond pas à
elles seules
vie dans la famille européenne ni cpi ni
les nôtres ne peuvent attendre pour
renforcer une cohésion qui est plus
nécessaire que jamais
c'est l'une des raisons pour lesquelles
le président de la république a proposé
de créer une communauté politique
européenne au sein de ce forum qui se
substituera pas aux organisations
existantes l'otan le conseil de l'europe
le 1e ou d'autres nous pourrons bâtir
des coopérations concrètes avec les pays
candidats sur de nombreux domaines mais
nous pourrons aussi approfondir les
discussions sur des sujets de sécurité
entre non seulement les pays candidats
blé tous les pays européens par la
géographie et par les valeurs
l'organisation par la présidence tchèque
en octobre prochain d'une première
réunion des chefs d'état ou de
gouvernement donnera ainsi le coup
d'envoi de cette nouvelle communauté
mesdames et messieurs les sénatrices et
sénateurs
cet agenda de souveraineté et c'est le
troisième volet de notre présidence nous
l'avons mis en oeuvre aussi bien sûr
dans le cadre du programme législatif
ambitieux que nous nous étions fixés à
l'origine et que nous avons mené à bien
dans tous les domaines je dois le dire
la tentation aurait pu être le 24
février de considérer qu'il n'y avait
plus pour les européens qu'un seul sujet
l'ukraine la gare en ukraine ses
conséquences la façon d'y répondre et
nous avons au contraire estimé que cette
guerre au coeur de l'europe ne faisait
que valider notre priorité la priorité
qui préexistait qui était au coeur de
notre présidence faire que l'europe soit
plus souveraine plus unie plus proche de
ses citoyens
et ainsi malgré la guerre nous avons
accéléré nos efforts nous l'avons fait
d'abord dans le domaine de la transition
écologique qui est pour nous tous un
objectif stratégique
l'accord obtenu au conseil ans
8 juin donc tout récemment presqu'à la
fin de notre présidence entre les états
membres sur le paquet climat fit for
fait chuter five comme on dit souvent à
bruxelles est une avancée majeure qui
doit assurer que nous réduirons de 55%
voilà notre ambition de 55% nos
émissions de co2 dans l'union européenne
en 2030 par rapport à 90 cela confirme
que l'europe entend continuer à être sur
la scène internationale à l'avant garde
du combat nécessaire pour répondre à
l'urgence climatique et cette transition
écologique car tout est lié elle est
également indispensable pour que
l'europe gagne en souveraineté
énergétique en réduisant sa dépendance
aux énergies fossiles
cet agenda écologique se traduira par
des bénéfices concrets pour nos
concitoyens dans leur vie quotidienne
avec par exemple mais on pourrait citer
d'autres c'est quand celui ci a été déjà
fort médiatisée la mise en place de
chargeur unique raconté de 2024 pour
tous les smartphones ordinateurs
portables et autres objets connectés
alors ça n'est pas anecdotique ce n'est
pas anecdotique parce que en effet
réutiliser un même chargeur pour tous
les appareils que nous avons nous
vie quotidienne je n'en doute pas mais
ça permettra aussi d'éviter des milliers
de tonnes de déchets électroniques
chaque année onze mille tonnes selon les
ong qui ont évalué ce que cela
représentait par an
enfin un accord a été trouvé entre les
états membres en vue d'un mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières pour
que nos efforts écologiques ne viennent
pas donner un avantage concurrentiel à
ceux qui n'en font pas c'est désormais
au parlement européen de se prononcer je
précise que l'enjeu est aussi
environnemental car ce mécanisme est
l'un des moyens les plus efficaces pour
lutter contre les fuites de carbone en
effet dès lors que ce mécanisme
empêchera les risques de concurrence
déloyale une entreprise européenne
n'aura plus de raison de se délocaliser
à l'extérieur de l'union pour espérer
bénéficier
de nos économies de nos emplois et du
climat c'est donc un pas extrêmement
important qui a été franchi
l'europe souveraine et c'est aussi
affirmé dans le domaine social l'europe
sociale on en parlait beaucoup il m'est
arrivé de le faire
dans d'autres circonstances et d'autres
temps
désormais elle prend corps et elle prend
encore en pleine cohérence avec le
modèle que la france a toujours défendu
chaque travailleur européen disposera
grâce la directive qui crée un cadre
commun sur le salaire minimum d'un
revenu minimal adéquat je voulais
souligner devant vous que c'est une
avancée majeure une véritable conquête
sociale à l'échelon européen ce socle
européen des droits sociaux que nous
appelons de nos voeux qui était une
promesse eh bien ils commencent
aujourd'hui à prendre forme et il prend
forme
je suis également fier que notre pays
fait adopter après dix ans de blocage
une directive fixant un objectif clair
aux entreprises au moins 40% de femmes
dans les conseils d'administration des
grandes entreprises en europe d'ici 2026
échéances rapprochées c'est une avancée
considérable
pour nous tous et pas seulement pour
nous tout une avancée considérable pour
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
égalité dans le président de la
république a fait pour son second mandat
comme il l'avait fait pour le premier
une priorité et je voudrais aussi
rappeler la proposition du président
annoncé le 19 janvier visant à inscrire
le droit à l'avortement dans la charte
européenne des droits fondamentaux
le parlement européen vous le savez la
reprise à son compte aujourd'hui et
alors évidemment où ce droit fondamental
est remis en cause dans une démocratie
aussi importantes que les états unis
l'europe doit d'autant plus porter ce
combat pour elle même et au delà de ses
frontières
nous avons également fait deux pas de
géant que j'ai hésité pour mieux réguler
le numérique je parle de l'adoption de
ces deux textes clés que sont la ctt sur
les services numériques et l'acte sur
les marchés numériques
texte qui auront un impact majeur sur
nos vies et celles des générations qui
nous suivent il s'agit bien sûr
d'empêcher les comportements
monopolistique des grandes plateformes
et les abus de position dominante qui
existe et c'est pas tant mais il s'agit
aussi de les contraindre à la
responsabilité et à la transparence sur
la suppression des contenus illicites
sur les réseaux sociaux ce qui n'est pas
permis hors ligne n'est pas permis en
ligne
car c'est peut-être
l'inquiéter l'une des principales
menaces pour eux nos démocraties des
réseaux sociaux sans loi livrer la loi
de la jungle et avec ce phénomène la
remise en cause de la validité de la
parole publique yle la validité d'un
débat éclairé entre les représentants
des citoyens
notre objectif désormais est que ces
textes européens deviennent des
références mondiales
en effet c'est ma conviction que
l'europe en se donnant des règles pour
elle-même est de fait en train de
contribuer à l'élaboration d'un
véritable ordre public international du
numérique pourquoi est ce que je vous
dis cela parce que nous l'avons vu déjà
depuis plusieurs années avec le fameux
rg qui est repris qui protège nos
droits et qui repris aujourd'hui par de
nombreux pays tiers et je ne doute pas
qu'il en ira de même avec ces deux
autres textes majeurs que nous venons
d'adopter sous présidence française et
qui répondent à des besoins fondamentaux
l'europe souveraine nous l'avons aussi
fait en sorte en définitivement l'europe
commercial de ce qu'on a pu appeler sa
naïveté
parce qu'elle considérait souvent le
commerce du seul point de vue économique
l'europe a été longtemps trop longtemps
prête à accepter des règles du jeu
asymétrique le choix de l'ouverture qui
était le sien depuis toujours devenez
pour nombre de nos citoyens est de plus
en plus synonyme de naïveté ça n'est
plus le cas à jour est cité trois
exemples
d'abord la mise en place d'un instrument
permettant une meilleure réciprocité en
matière d'accès aux marchés publics les
entreprises chinoises par exemple ne
pourront répondre à des appels d'offres
sinoise par exemple ne pourront répondre
à des appels d'offres en europe que si
nos entreprises sont autorisés à faire
de même en chine c'est un progrès majeur
sur lequel nous avons travaillé depuis
15 ans là aussi vous me pardonnerez de
faire référence à m'en passer mais dans
d'autres fonctions traitant également
des affaires européennes je me souviens
qu'il ya 15 ans c'était déjà le combat
du gouvernement de la france
de la même manière autre exemple les
états tirent subventionnant à outrance
leur entreprise et on peut penser là
encore à la chine mais pas uniquement
donc venant ainsi faussé la concurrence
au sein de notre marché intérieur
seront sanctionnés par la commission
européenne grâce à l'accord qui a été
trouvé au conseil au tout dernier jour
de notre présidence sur l'instrument de
lutte contre les subventions étrangères
et troisième exemple nous avons promu
également un renforcement des règles
protectrices pour la santé des
consommateurs via ce qu'on appelle des
mesures miroir qui permettent d'imposer
aux produits importés les mêmes règles
que celles que nous appliquons pour nos
productions au sein de l'union
ce sont là trois exemples et trois
exemples que j'ai choisi parce que il
part je pense très concrètement à nos
concitoyens à nos entrepreneurs et aux
salariés de notre pays
la vérité il vous m'avez entendu sa
référence au passé par deux fois c'est
que cela faisait longtemps que la france
porte et ses questions au plan européen
sans être toujours entendu sinon c'est
sur yon rêver plus vite et certains des
partenaires vous vous en souvenez je
m'en souviens en tout cas voyez même une
certaine forme de protectionnisme dans
notre plaidoyer
aujourd'hui les temps ont changé nous
avons saisi l'occasion de notre
présidence pour faire qu' il y ait des
résultats sur chacun de ces domaines et
les résultats sont là l'europe est
désormais beaucoup mieux armées pour
protéger et protéger réellement
efficacement nos intérêts et nos emplois
affirmé notre souveraineté nous l'avons
encore fait en renforçant l'espace
schengen et en débloquant les
discussions sur le pacte asile
immigration qui sont des sujets majeurs
également
l'espace schengen nous l'avons renforcé
en réaffirmant son pilotage politique
par la création d'un conseil des
ministres schengen qui se réunira
régulièrement puis en revoyant les
règles qui régissent la gestion des
frontières internes et externes de
l'union on sait qu'il n'ya pas de
réponse nationale qu'ils soient
suffisantes pour faire face aux défis
migratoires et la réponse allait
forcément aussi européennes et
internationales et européennes d'abord
dès lors que nous partageons un même
espace de libre circulation pour nos
concitoyens
au sein de l'union européenne
la seule réponse efficace et donc celle
de la responsabilité renforcée des pays
de premières entrée qui a été rappelé et
tout doit bien sûr aller de pair avec la
solidarité des autres états membres
vis-à-vis des pays tiers singulièrement
vis-à-vis des pays d'origine il faut
aussi une approche équilibrée continue à
porter notre effort en matière de
développement car on sait bien que c'est
l'un des fondements majeurs des
migrations
c'est l'absence de perspective pour deux
très nombreuses personnes des pays les
moins développés qui les pousse à
entreprendre le voyage migratoire et
cette politique portant n'exclut
nullement la fermeté dont il faut savoir
faire preuve par exemple lorsque
certains pays tiers refuse d'admettre
sur leur territoire de réadmettre les
ressortissants qui sont entrés
illégalement sur le territoire européen
et qui donc n'ont pas vocation à l'asile
selon notre droit et c'est cette logique
fondée sur le respect des équilibres
nécessaires indispensables même qui nous
a permis d'obtenir en juin d'importantes
avancées en particulier s'agissant d'un
contrôle renforcé des migrants à leur
arrivée sur le territoire européen
enfin sur notre présidence nous avons
accompagné des travaux de la conférence
sur l'avenir de l'europe nous avions
invité les citoyens à écrire le prochain
chapitre de notre union dans le cadre
d'un exercice
participatif qui est un exercice inédit
les membres du gouvernement sont allés à
la rencontre des françaises et des
français dans toutes les régions de
france entre mai 2021 aimé 2022 donc
toute une année pour recueillir les
propositions ces propositions ont été
présentées à l'échelon européen le 9 mai
vous avez entendu le président de la
république et elles doivent attentes
trouver une réponse concrète c'est l'une
des priorités de la présidence tchèque
qui prend le relais de la nôtre
la france bien sûr prendra toute sa part
à la traduction de ses priorités
enfin c'est le quatrième et dernier
volet de notre présidence c'est aussi
avec nos partenaires à l'extérieur de
l'europe qu'il nous faut aujourd'hui
bâtir les conditions de notre
indépendance et notre prospérité
j'ai souligné une évidence une part de
notre avenir se joue dans notre capacité
à renforcer nos partenariats avec les
grandes régions du monde dans un monde
tu es plus que jamais globalisé et les
interdépendances sont soulignés chaque
jour je pense en premier lieu à
l'afrique l'afrique que la présidence
française avait misé
au coeur de la pf lieu avec le sommet
union européenne union africaine des 17
et 18 février
nous avons lancé tous ensemble européen
un projet de refondation du partenariat
entre l'europe et l'afrique car il est
nécessaire
projet centré autour des questions
économiques mais aussi de la formation
et de la jeunesse et nous resterons bien
sûr au delà de notre présidence très
engagée pour participer à sa mise en
oeuvre vous avez entendu la première
ministre je pense dans son discours de
politique générale je pense également à
l'inde au pacifique région la france est
présente puisque la france est aussi un
pays du pacifique et de l'océan indien
région vitale pour nos exportations et
nos approvisionnements mais région qui
fait face à la pression de la présence
croissante de la chine si donc une
nécessité absolue pour nous de nous y
impliquer en tant que puissance et
nations du pacifique grâce à la présence
et à la force de nos territoires ultra
marins mais aussi c'est une chose
nécessaire pour les grands équilibres du
monde c'est pourquoi nous avons organisé
sous présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne le 1er forum
ministériel
u11 2 pacifique à paris le 22 février et
qui a permis d'avancer sur trois sujets
de façon concrète des projets de
sécurité défense de connectivité et de
numérique et les enjeux globaux ont
également été ciblés comme la troisième
priorité
je me félicite que l'union européenne
est adopté cette stratégie c'est une
région clé une partie de notre avenir
ces jours là aussi la présidence tchèque
prendra le relais et je pense
également bien sûr partenariat
transatlantique
car nous savons qu aucun des grands
défis qu'ils soient numériques j'en
parlais beaucoup écologique commerciaux
internationaux ne pourrait être réglé
sans une coopération étroite entre
l'europe et les états unis étaient unis
qui mesure je crois aujourd'hui combien
l'union européenne peut également être
utile aux équilibres du monde et s'est
égaré
le sommet de l'otan s'est tenue il ya
quelques semaines je me félicite que
sous présidence française le sommet
permis
de pousser auprès de nos amis et alliés
une meilleure appréciation de la
contribution de ce que l'union
européenne apporte à la défense et la
sécurité de tous les alliés le concept
stratégique adopté lors du sommet de
madrid reflète reflète cette
complémentarité cet équilibre et vous
vous prononcerez bientôt mesdames la
sénatrice messieurs les sénateurs sur la
ratification de l'accord autorisant la
suède et la finlande à l'alliance
atlantique un choix qui était le leur
une adhésion qui renforcera notre
sécurité collective comme elle
renforcera la place des européens au
sein de l'alliance
dernière région que je veux évoquer les
balkans occidentaux
région stratégique et régions encore
trop troublé région stratégique qu'on ne
doit pas laisser dériver loin de la
famille européenne a fortiori dans un
contexte où des puissances tierces
n'hésiteront pas et on le voit déjà à
occuper lé vide politique et stratégique
que nous aurions laissé
les pays de la région sont sur le chemin
de l'adhésion d'un chemin qui est
exigeant et difficile
leur marche dépend avant tout de même
mais notre intérêt c'est de les
accompagner c'est pourquoi nous avons
organisé en marge du dernier conseil
européen de juin donc le 23 juin une
réunion avec les chefs d'état ou de
gouvernement des balkans occidentaux
pour réaffirmer leur perspective
européenne est rappelé que la marche à
suivre de notre côté et claire du leurre
elle doit l'être aussi vous connaissez
les difficultés qu'ont quelques pays à
régler leurs sujets bilatéraux
ses succès mais à messieurs les
sénatrices et sénateurs je voudrais
aussi dire qu'ils nous les devons
d'abord bien sûr au président de la
république qui a mis
depuis sa première élection 2017 qui a
mis le rap au coeur de son projet
politique et qui apporte l agenda et la
vision de notre présidence mais je veux
aussi saluer au delà du chef de l'état
l'action de tout le gouvernement
autour du jean castex puis autour de la
première ministre elisabeth bornes salue
aussi celle du secrétariat général des
affaires européennes
le secrétariat général de la présidence
française celle de tous les ministères
et de tous leurs agents ont été
mobilisés pendant des mois et des mois
et bien avant le début de la présidence
française pour concevoir ce que nous
ferions puis animé la présidence réussir
ces négociations faire vivre le projet
européen je salue aussi tous les
territoires qui ont vu les collectivités
se mobilisent et tous les citoyens qui
ont participé au débat sur l'europe et
partout la société civile qui s'empare
et je m'en félicite
peu à peu du projet européen et enfin je
veux saluer bien sûr avec laurence boone
l'action déterminante de mon
prédécesseur jean yves le drian qui à ma
place a conduit pendant cinq mois les
travaux de la présidence française et
celle de clément bonne ils ont mené ils
ont mené la pf lieu à bon port et enfin
comme ministre de l'europe et des
affaires étrangères ayant succédé à jean
yves le drian je veux dire bien sûr et
je souhaite leur dire solennellement
devant vous ma fierté du travail qui a
été accompli par tous nos diplomates et
agents du quai d'orsay à paris à la
représentation permanente auprès de
l'union européenne à bruxelles et dans
toutes nos ambassades en europe et
partout dans le monde voilà ce que je
voulais vous dire mes amis et messieurs
les sénatrices et sénateurs sur cette
13e à présidence depuis le début de la
construction européenne alors le 30 juin
j'ai symboliquement passé le témoin le
relais le bâton comme l'ont dit mais je
mets des guillemets s'il vous plaît
n'est pas mauvais esprits à la
présidence tchèque à mon collègue yann
n'allait pas ce qui
nous pouvons être fiers je crois de
laisser à la présidence tchèque une
europe qui n'hésitent plus mais sa
souveraineté qui osent défendre ses
intérêts stratégiques et économiques
est ce qu'il faut de clarté et de
fermeté pour se faire respecter mieux
qu'auparavant la fin de la présidence
française puisqu'elle est derrière nous
depuis le 30 juin ne signifie pas que
nous abandonnons les priorités qui sont
les nôtres bien au contraire vous pouvez
compter sur ma détermination sur celle
de laurent seconde c'est surtout le
gouvernement pour faire en sorte que les
résultats de la présence française et
s'aiment bien au delà de ces six mois
nous travaillons très étroitement avec
nos partenaires
d'abord un partenaire tchèque puis
suédois au sein de ce qu'on appelle le
trio de présidences puisque nous formons
un trio et nous travaillons aussi avec
tous nos autres partenaires au premier
chef l'allemagne puisque nous sommes 27
ensemble dans la même aventure en
n'oubliant jamais que notre devoir est
de bâtir au service de nos concitoyens
une europe encore plus forte encore plus
soudé encore plus durable en amont plus
souveraine
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
mes chers collègues j'ai le plaisir de
saluer
j'ai le plaisir de saluer dans la
tribune d'honneur une délégation de
sénateurs du groupe d'amitié france
d'une part son président monsieur pillot
garcia escudero marquez qui présida le
sénat espagnol de 2011 à 2019 est
accompagné par son excellence monsieur
victor et donne aux ambassadeurs de
france d'espagne en france par monts et
par mon collègue michel meunier et
françois bonhomme président et vice
président du groupe d'amitié
lors de sa visite en loire atlantique la
délégation a notamment visité les
chantiers navals de saint nazaire elle
sera reçue demain en audience à la
présidence avant une série d'entretiens
institutionnel la coopération bilatérale
entre l'espagne et la france nous le
savons est solide que ce soit en
sécurité en politiques énergétiques ou
encore dans les domaines scientifique et
universitaire la présence de nos
homologues espagnols à l'occasion de ce
débat sur le bilan de la présidence
française du conseil de l'union est un
signe fort des liens d'amitié qui relie
nos deux pays elle revêt une portée
symbolique que je me permets de
souligner
prenons à tous permettez moi de
souhaiter à la délégation espagnole la
plus cordiale bienvenue ainsi qu'un
excellent et fructueux séjour
[Applaudissements]
la parole est maintenant aux présidents
jean françois rapin
[Applaudissements]
monsieur monsieur le président madame
mesdames les ministres mais madame la
ministre parce que madame vous nous a
quittés mes chers collègues le
gouvernement a dressé son propre bilan
de la présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne en forme de
panégyriques cela n'étonnera personne si
l'on s'en tenait au dossier de presse
qui l'a publié nous pourrions en rester
là et notre séance n'aurait pas lieu
d'être mais permettez-moi de gratter le
vernis car tout ce qui brille n'est pas
de l'or il est de notre responsabilité
de ne pas passer sous silence les zones
d'ombré et les angles morts de cette
présidence française elle s'est donc
déroulée au premier semestre 2022 malgré
et nous l'avions déploré la concomitance
d'échéances électorales importantes pour
notre pays c'était un choix du président
de la république qui aurait pu demander
un report de fait même si nos diplomates
ont pu arracher d accord in extremis au
conseil ce fut tout au plan politique
une présidence tronquée la france a
manqué de temps pour convaincre ses
partenaires sur certains dossiers je
pense notament notamment au texte sur le
financement des partis politiques
européens et la transparence de la
publicité politique que le président de
la république affiché comme une priorité
pour renforcer la démocratie en europe
je ne nie pas que dans l'ensemble les
grands dossiers européens est avancé
sous présidence française
mais ces avancées tiennent autant voire
plus à la commission européenne c'est la
commission qui a donné le tempo elle a
suivi son programme de travail est
publié les textes annoncé aux dates
prévues
côté conseil la présidence française
avait de toute façon rétréci par rapport
à 2008 en 2022 le conseil européen
n'était plus présidé par la france
puisqu'il existe dorénavant dorénavant
un président permanent du conseil
européen charles michel idem pour le
conseil des affaires étrangères
présidait depuis le traité de lisbonne
par le haut représentant de l'union
aujourd'hui josep borrell dans ce
costume et 3 la france a consenti de
réels efforts pour favoriser l'obtention
de compromis au conseil le gouvernement
les brandit le mail mais il se garde de
distinguer les accords au petit
politiques obtenus et les initiatives
simplement lancé mais loin d'aboutir et
ils négligent le poids du parlement
européen qui pourrait bien à l'issue des
trilogues délicat qui s'annonce dernière
certains résultats déjà hâtivement
annoncé venons en au fond comme en 2008
la présidence française fut à nouveau
bouleversé par une crise d'envergure
cette fois-ci géostratégie l'union
européenne s'est mobilisé pour répondre
à l'agression russe de l'ukraine
j'y étais il y a quelques jours avec le
président on larcher quelle tristesse
mais aussi qu'elle résilience du peuple
ukrainien sous l'impulsion française
lignon a réagi vite et bien et il le
fallait pour aider militairement
l'ukraine sanctionner la russie en cinq
paquets accueillir 5 millions de
réfugiés ukrainien leur accorder une
protection temporaire et une aide
humanitaire
réorienter son approvisionnement
énergétique sa crise ukrainienne at-elle
interférer avec les priorités de la
présidence française
paradoxalement on peut considérer
qu'elle a plutôt servi l'ambition
française d'amener l'europe à se penser
comme une puissance elle a en effet
donné des arguments à l'impératif de
souveraineté stratégique pour lequel la
france plaidait depuis longtemps et que
refuser d'entendre certains états
membres mais ne nous réjouissons pas
trop vite ainsi en matière de défense
l'activation de la facilité européenne
pour la paix l'adoption de la boussole
stratégiques le renforcement des
investissements européens de la défense
décidé à versailles sont autant d'étapes
décisives mais le retour en force de
l'otan et leurs équipements militaires
accélérée des états membres profitent
surtout aux états unis
et rien ne garantit que l'effort
d'investissement annoncées aille à
l'industrie militaire européenne
monsieur le président en matière
d'énergie les importations de charbon et
pétrole russes sont bannis un partage
solidaire des installations de stockage
et des réserves stratégiques de gaz sont
prévus le développement des énergies
renouvelables sera accélérée mais ceci
ne suffira pas à rendre l'europe
souveraine cela pourrait même la faire
entrer dans de nous dépendance déjà par
rapport à des fournisseurs alternatifs
d'énergie fossile mais aussi par rapport
à la chine dont l'europe a besoin pour
se doter des batteries électriques et
des panneaux photovoltaïques requis pour
ses ambitions climatiques en matière
spatiale le volontarisme français a
accéléré la décision de mettre en place
une constellation de connectivité
sécurisée européenne c'est un élément
important de souveraineté mais là aussi
ne cédons pas au triomphalisme qui
arrive y ait encore un long chemin à
parcourir technologiques et financiers
et nous espérons que notre lanceur
ariane 6 dans le cadre de la préférence
européenne sera prêt et disponible pour
la mise en place de cette constellation
autre avancée valorisé par le
gouvernement les nouveaux outils de
régulation au service de la souveraineté
numérique les accords sur les textes ds
à et dma qui régule services et marchés
numériques sont aussi une bonne nouvelle
pour freiner la domination pardon des
grandes plateformes mais au plan
industriel ne rêvons pas rien ne dit par
exemple que le european chips acte
permettra d'augmenter la production
européenne de puces d'efforts financiers
européens pour elle a encore bénéficié à
des entreprises étrangères même si ce
matin nous avons entendu les annonces
porté par la présidence sur les
investissements en france
surtout le développement d'écosystèmes
industriels européens restent entravées
par le statu quo des règles de
concurrence européennes qui empêche
toujours les concentrations nécessaires
à l'émergence des champions européens
plus grave que les zones d'ombré sont
les angles morts de la présidence
française
le premier à mes yeux c'est la
souveraineté alimentaire il est frappant
de nous trouver aucune allusion dans le
bilan publié par le gouvernement sur son
semestre de présidence en dépit de nos
demandes répétées en dépit de
l'électrochoc du coc vide puis de celui
de la guerre en ukraine la nouvelle pac
reste 'ordonné' reste ordonné à son
verdissement et délaissent les objectifs
de production et ce malgré le spectre de
pénuries alimentaires mondiales
deuxième silence inquiétant de la
présidence française la sécurité aux
frontières européennes
la france vient de perdre la direction
de lagence la plus puissante de l'union
européenne l' agence frontex son
directeur exécutif a démissionné
abandonné en rase campagne par notre
gouvernement il ne suffisait pas de
désembourber les négociations sur le
projet de pacte asile immigration
il aurait aussi fallu affirmer haut et
fort que la mission de frontex et de
surveiller les frontières extérieures
dans le respect des droits fondamentaux
n'ont pas de contrôler le respect par
les états membres des droits
fondamentaux une autre agence européenne
s'y emploie déjà
3e lacunes de la présidence française la
zone euro le débat attendu sur
l'évolution du pacte de stabilité et de
croissance n'a pas eu lieu des écarts de
taux réapparaissent à la faveur des
dettes qu vide et de l'inflation et
menace la cohésion de la zone euro en
outre l'union bancaire ne progresse pas
son troisième pilier la garantie des
dépôts fait cruellement défaut je
m'inquiète enfin de notre crédibilité
sur les marchés dès lors que l'union n'a
toujours pas finalisé les nouvelles
ressources propres qui permettront de
rembourser le plan de relance européen
quatrième négligence française
l'appartenance
c'était pourtant l'un des trois axes que
le gouvernement avait retenu pour sa
présidence les urgences du moment ne
doivent pas nous détourner de cet
impératif qui concilie conditionne
l'avenir l'avenir de l'union consolidé
l'adhésion populaire au projet européen
spécialement parmi pour les jeunes et ce
d'autant plus que l'union entend
s'élargir encore cela passe par une
démocratisation de l'union européenne à
laquelle les parlements nationaux
peuvent contribuer au premier chef c'est
précisément sur cette dimension
parlementaire que je veux conclure car
la présidence française n'a pas été
seulement la sphère du gouvernement elle
a été aussi elle a aussi mobilisé le
parlement et au premier chef le sénat
qui a assuré la continuité parlementaire
au long du semestre nous avons oeuvré au
renforcement du rôle des parlements
nationaux dans l'union européenne afin
de rendre son fonctionnement plus
démocratique
après un colloque universitaire organisé
ici sur ce thème dès décembre dernier
j'ai porté avec mon homologue de
l'assemblée nationale une redynamisation
de la cosac conférence qui réunit les
organes par le des parlements nationaux
spécialisés dans les affaires de l'union
nous avons innové en lançant son sein de
groupes de travail celui que je
présidais s'est consacré au rôle des
parlements nationaux dans l'union et au
terme de quatre mois de travail intensif
entre parlementaires de toute l'union il
a pu adopter des conclusions le 14 juin
dernier parmi les 14 propositions
avancées par ce groupe je souhaite en
souligner deux d'une part la mise en
place d'un droit d'initiative commun et
indirects des parlements nationaux ou
carton vert nous proposons un dispositif
concret directement applicables sous
réserve que la commission européenne en
acceptent le principe
serait ainsi reconnu aux parlements
nationaux un rôle actif dans la
construction européenne d'autre part un
droit de questionnements écrit des
institutions européennes pour les
présidents des commissions des affaires
européennes de chacune des deux chambres
sur le modèle de celui dont disposent
les eurodéputés un tel outil nous
permettrait de mieux participer au
contrôle des politiques européennes
autant de voies d'avenir que nous
espérons voir prospérer madame la
ministre soûlé prochaine présidence je
vous remercie
dans la suite du débat la parole des
orateurs des groupes et le commençons
par le président pierre laurent qui l'a
s'exprimer pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen écologistes
monsieur le président mesdames les
ministres chers collègues le choix
d'assumer la présidence française en
pleine campagne électorale était
discutable mais une fois fait cela rap
us cela aurait pu avoir du sens s'il
s'était agi d'ouvrir un grand débat
démocratique sur l'avenir de l'union
dans un moment historique crucial mais
une fois encore le débat n'a pas eu lieu
la non campagne électorale du président
en france et une conférence sur l'avenir
de l'europe demeurer clandestine pour la
grande majorité des européens en ont
scellé le sort c'est la guerre en
ukraine qui a tout bousculé diront
certains c'est vrai l'agression russe a
changé la donne mais elle aurait dû
renforcer l'exigence d'euros fondation
européenne pour rebâtir la puissance
d'avenir que revendiquait le président
macron en ces termes devant le parlement
européen je cite une europe apte à
répondre aux défis climatiques
technologiques numériques mais aussi
géopolitique une europe indépendante en
ce qu'elle se donne encore les moyens de
décider pour elles mêmes de son avenir
et de ne pas dépendre des choix des
autres grandes puissances
mais loin d'une puissance retrouvée par
une autonomie stratégique reconstruite
l'union européenne toujours faim
fracturé sort de cette présidence en
puissance passif c'est-à-dire plus que
jamais dépendante de l'action des
puissances extérieures les etats unis
auront ainsi signé sous présidence
française leur grand retour au coeur des
choix européens le président macron
promettait pour l'europe autonomie
stratégique et reconstruction des
souverainetés or avant même le
déclenchement de l'agression russe en
ukraine il était déjà écrit que
l'autonomie stratégique promise dont la
boussole stratégique ne serait qu'un
complément de l'otan six mois plus tard
c'est en réalité le document stratégique
de l'otan l'otan d'ailleurs que vous
n'avez même pas cité une seule fois dans
votre invention madame la ministre le
document stratégique de l'otan à madrid
écrit sous la dictée américaine qui
devient de fait la doctrine européenne
avec à la clé entre autres choses
d'immenses perspectives de ventes
d'armes américaines sur le sol européen
face à une guerre qui la menace au
premier chef l'europe l'itu sont sources
tout son sort à la politique américaine
d'idées elle par l'obsession de la
confrontation avec la chine la voix de
l'europe sa ligne au moment où nous
aurions au contraire besoin qu'elle
s'affirme et qu'elle affirme sa capacité
d'initiative propre l'avenir il est
jeune et énergétique de l'europe est lui
aussi en cause le gaz illustre par
exemple un périlleux transfert de
dépendance du gaz russe au gaz naturel
américain
c'est un mouvement qui s'était
d'ailleurs amorcé avant la guerre
d'ukraine entre 2016 et 2021 les
importations en europe de gaz naturel
liquéfié ont été multipliées par 20 nous
n'arrêterons pas la 15 milliards de
mètres cubes abreuveront l'europe dès
2022 50 milliards de plus par an jusqu'à
la fin de la décennie de quoi raviver
les projets d'investissements américains
massifs dans les terminaux méthaniers
or 80% de la production américaine et u6
du gaz de schiste un comble au moment où
nous parlons d'ambitionner la neutralité
carbone en 2050 sur 20 ans le pouvoir de
réchauffement de ce gaz et 81 super 80
fois supérieur à celui du co2 que dire
encore de notre souveraineté alimentaire
et de l'énième accords de libre échange
qui a été signé avec la nouvelle zélande
dans les derniers jours de la présidence
française et j'ai une question madame la
ministre le parlement français sera-t-il
à l'instar du ceta uniquement là pour
constater les dégâts écologiques et
économiques de ces accords de cet accord
sont jamais pouvoir en discuter comme la
couche d'ozone le paquet climat européen
commence lui aussi à avoir vraiment
beaucoup de trous s'ils continuent
d'afficher de grandes ambitions la
dimension socialement juste de cette
transition ne cesse de s'étioler au fil
des discussions
ainsi l'adoption la fin des
immatriculations de véhicules thermiques
et hybrides et l'instauration d'un
marché carbone pour le transport routier
et le chauffage sont des bombes à
retardement sociale et sociétale
dans un contexte de prix de l'essence
élevé ce nouveau marché carbone aboutir
à deux fêtes à une forme de taxe carbone
européenne frappant sans distinction
ménages et entreprises risquant
d'aggraver les précarité énergétique et
les fractures face au droit à la
mobilité en effet le fonds social pour
le climat qu'il aurait fallu dans ces
conditions massive le renforcer a été
finalement plafonné à 50 milliards
d'euros sans co financement des états la
soutenabilité même des mutations de la
production et des modes de vie et donc
menacés
dans ces conditions madame la ministre
je vous le demande que confère la france
pour demander enfin la révision complète
du marché européen de l'électricité
que le président de la république résumé
de cette formule une forme d'impôt de
l'extérieur qui vient par le gaz et
l'électricité quand allons nous sortir
de ce système responsable d'une
inflation particulièrement pénalisantes
une fois encore l'europe sociale est
restée la grande oubliée la directive
sur le salaire minimum car on parle
enfin de salaire minimum en europe
soixante ans après la création de
l'union européenne ne comporte aucune
disposition contraignante et le deal
dumping social reste donc risque de
rester dans ces conditions la règle en
europe les incitations de la directive
est en encore extrêmement timide même si
elles sont bienvenus
les hauts revenus eux continueront de
battre des records en toute indécence
dans toute l'europe
ah oui j'allais oublier effectivement
vous l'avez citer une autre avancée
majeure sociale sous présidence
française après dix ans de négociations
elle obligera à accorder au moins 40%
des postes d'administrateurs dans les
sociétés cotées en bourse à des
dirigeantes donc l'égalité progresse au
cac 40 c'est une bonne nouvelle en
réalité l'europe ne retrouve ni souffle
ni ambition pour son avenir car elle ne
conçoit sa souveraineté que comme un
repli ainsi vient-elle sous présidence
française
d'enterrer l'esprit du pack global pour
la migration déposé il ya près de deux
ans par la commission européenne et qui
prônait la notion de solidarité
obligatoire
au contraire le texte final avalise le
recul de nos valeurs d'accueil car les
migrations ne sont vus que comme une
menace même la crise ukrainienne ne nous
aura pas aidé à réfléchir au fond sur
l'avenir de cette question toute la
négociation aura été mené sous la
pression du courrier indigne co signé en
octobre dernier par 12 ministre de
l'intérieur et adresser aux institutions
européennes qui a appelé au
rétablissement des murs financé par le
budget de l'ue aux frontières de l'union
l'accord obtenu reste dominée par celle
du partage du fardeau migratoires la
présidence française a subi les
événements et aura manqué a lancé les
grands débats d'avenir
j'aurais pu certes relevé les premières
avancées réelles celles-là vers la
reconstruction une souveraineté
numérique au premier rang desquels les
règlements ds a aidé m à mais les
révélations sur hubert noirci
sérieusement le tableau car elle montre
au fond qu'on est loin d'avoir fini de
la connivence entre les pouvoirs
politiques et les puissances d'argent
dont les gars femmes à ce propos le rock
numérique ne peut se faire sur le dos
des travailleurs des plateformes
pourquoi madame la ministre la france
traîne les pieds sur le projet de
directive qui permet enfin de
reconnaître la présomption de salariat
et de reconnaître les droits attachés à
cette présomption de salariat
plus fondamentalement
le temps est venu de se préparer il faut
le craindre à une nouvelle crise
financière à une récession qui menace il
faut dès lors rouvrir le débat sur la
mobilisation des financements sur la
mobilisation d'investissements publics
massifs
alors qu'au contraire nous voyons
revenir le refrain de la dette et de la
compression des dépenses publiques
qu'est devenu le débat promis sur la
révision du pacte de stabilité qu'en le
parlement pourra t'il enfin discuter les
soi-disant nouvelles règles qu'on nous
promet nous ne pourrons plus longtemps
madame la ministre éviter d'affronter
des choix politiques
seul à même de dégager les perspectives
de financement nécessaire je vous
remercie
la parole à présent et à notre collègue
claude kern pour le groupe de l'union
centriste
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues lors de sa
conférence de presse du 9 décembre 2021
le président de la république avait
présenté un programme ambitieux pour la
présidence française de l'union
européenne fondée autour de 3 ambitions
une europe plus souveraine une europe
plus humaine eneurope basée sur un
modèle sur un nouveau modèle de
croissance
malgré d'éruptions de la guerre sur
notre vieux continent qui a bouleversé
le programme que la france s'était fixé
les objectifs
fixés lors de la conférence du 9
décembre ont pour la plupart été atteint
nombre d'observateurs avisés qualifie
donc cette présidence de réussite car 97
% des objectifs annoncés en décembre ont
été atteints
je pense premièrement à l'accord
l'accord final sur les textes et emma et
ds à fournissant de nouvelles armes face
aux gaffes à ces deux textes permettront
de mieux anticiper les dérives abus des
distorsions de concurrence se dégagera
les avancées sont réelles sur de
nombreux thèmes tout d'abord sociaux
avec l'accord trouvé sur la directive
relative aux salaires minimaux adéquat
ou avec l'accord sur la proportion de
femmes dans les conseils
d'administration des entreprises cotées
en bourse au sein de l'ue et qui devra
atteindre 40% à l'horizon 2026
avancé également sur le thème de la
consommation avec la mise en place d'un
chargeur unique est compatible avec
toutes les marques de smartphones
liseuses ou casque enfin je salue les
accords trouvés à la toute fin de la
présidence française sur l'état cinq
textes phares du plan climat ayant pour
but de réduire de 55 % nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre d'ici 2050
le tournant qu'a connue votre présidence
à partir du 24 février dernier a permis
de donner du corps à l'idée française de
souveraineté stratégique l'autre succès
à mettre à votre crédit et le maintien
de l'union des 27 états membres face à
la mise en place des sanctions contre la
russie les vingt-sept ont fait preuve de
solidarité avec l'ukraine en
sanctionnant moscou à six reprises avec
des embargos sur le charbon le gaz et le
pétrole ils ont également acté les
livraisons d'armes à kiev il ya la
facilité européenne pour la paix l'union
européenne a offert un refuge aux
ukrainiens fuyant les bombes russe avec
l'activation d'un mécanisme d'accueil
d'urgence utilisé pour la première fois
deux prises depuis sa création il ya
vingt ans
c'est également dans ce contexte de
guerre aux portes de l'union européenne
que les états membres ont réussi à
trouver un accord le 25 mars sur leur
boussole stratégique en matière de
défense
l'accord initial a d'ailleurs été musclé
au regard des événements auxquels notre
continent fait face
l'un des enjeux derrière la définition
de cette boussole stratégique a été de
parvenir à définir un consensus entre
les 27 états membres de l'ue eux tant
sur la perception des menaces qui pèsent
sur leur sécurité que sur les moyens d'y
faire face ensemble
de par leur histoire les pays européens
disposent de culture stratégique
différente et non pas nécessairement la
même analyse la même analyse pardon des
menaces et des priorités en matière de
sécurité et de défense
la boussole stratégique consiste donc à
identifier les priorités sur lesquelles
les européens sont prêts à s'investir
collectivement sur les plan géopolitique
est opérationnel ce texte qui sera notre
fil conducteur de la politique de
sécurité de défense européenne jusqu'en
2030 est donc une véritable avancée pour
un esprit européen de la défense
enfin nous avons accordé à l'ukraine et
à la moldavie le statut de candidat de
candidat à l'adhésion a lieu le 23 juin
dans un délai particulièrement rapide
signal fort envoyé et à la russie et à
l'ukraine et son peuple je me félicite
de cette décision même si
personnellement je ne suis pas un adepte
de l'élargissement trop rapide tout en
re tout en regrettant qu'il n'ait pas pu
être en être de même pour la géorgie
mais je pense que nous en reparlerons la
guerre en ukraine a remis la question de
la sobriété énergétique au sommet des
priorités à ce titre la question
énergétique est en quête des objectifs
de la république tchèque est en tête des
objectifs de la république tchèque qui
occupe la présidence tournante de lieux
depuis le 1er juillet dès le sommet des
chefs d'état et de gouvernement de
versailles qui s'est tenu en mars 2022
la question de l'énergie avait été
centrales et les états s'étaient engagés
à réduire notre dépendance énergétique
tout en maintenant l'objectif de
neutralité climatique d'ici à 2050
presque quatre mois après ce sommet les
inquiétudes demeurent
l'invasion de l'ukraine à un lourd
impact sur l'augmentation des prix
énergétiques et les actions
perturbatrices de la russie sur le
marché du gaz contribuent également à
l'augmentation du prix des denrées
alimentaires et des matières premières
les conclusions du dernier conseil
européen sur ce sujet ne sont pas
rassurantes de nombreux constats ont été
faits plusieurs pistes pour atténuer la
hausse des prix énergétiques ont été
étudiées sans que certaines soient
définitivement arrêté alors que les
réductions de livraisons de gaz russe
aux pays de l'union européenne sans
chaînes près de douze états sont
désormais touchés par des coupures
unilatérale de gaz de la paire de parts
de la russie et l'allemagne restant dans
une totale incertitude quant à la
réactivation de son gazoduc north stream
nous sommes incapables aujourd'hui de
proposer des solutions efficaces et
efficientes la seule avancée que nous
pouvons saluer à ce stade et la décision
du parlement européen du 6 juillet
dernier d'inscrire le nucléaire et de
gaz parmi les énergies vertes dans
l'union européenne afin d'y attirer
attirer les investissements publics et
privés on nous dit que la commission
travaille à un plan d'urgence de
réduction de la demande d'énergie sans
que celle ci ne semble être en mesure
d'arrêter des décisions dès lors
plusieurs comme question s'impose non
quelles pistes seront privilégiés par la
france notamment le 26 juillet prochain
lors du sommet des ministres de
l'énergie
comment faire pour éviter une
fragmentation des no 27 états membres
sur cette question quelles actions sont
menées pour nous préparer dès maintenant
à une réduction voire à une coupure
complète des approvisionnements russes
cet hiver les réductions de livraisons
de gaz vers l'europe opéré ces dernières
semaines par moscou laisse craindre le
pire et doivent nous pousser à nous
préparer dès maintenant à une rupture
complète de l'approvisionnement en cas
d'interruption totale un rationnement
pourrait être prononcée dès cet hiver et
cela entraînerait une destruction de la
demande aux conséquences désastreuses
pour nos économies dès lors deux
questions se posent quels nouveaux
partenaires l'union européenne
favorisera-t-elle pour sécuriser ses
apports et enfin les objectif de
neutralité carbone sont ils toujours
tenable dans ce contexte notre part la
présidence française de l'union
européenne a enfin vu aboutir la
conférence pour l'avenir de l'europe
avec un retard d'un an crise sanitaire
oblige
cet exercice inédit de réflexion des
débats sur l'avenir de l'europe
largement encouragée par la france et
plus particulièrement par le président
macron a abouti à 49 propositions pour
rapprocher les institutions européennes
des citoyens
si lors de la remise du rapport le 9 mai
dernier un élan s'était fait ressentir
le sujet n'a été que brièvement abordé
au dernier conseil européen ne laissant
pas présager d'évolution rapide mais des
buts les députés européens avaient
pourtant voté une résolution saluant et
approuvant ces conclusions et le travail
de cette conférence sur l'avenir de
l'europe avait été saluée par la
présidente van der leyen
l'évolution de nos institutions est une
nécessité pour répondre aux défis
auxquels l'union européenne est
confrontée
quel levier allez vous activer pour
soutenir la volonté de mettre fin à la
règle de l'unanimité pour certaines
décisions prises au sein du conseil de
l'union européenne
par exemple en matière budgétaire
fiscale ou concernant la paix au cs
ce mode de vaud de vote très lourd peut
parfois devenir un frein à l'action de
l'union européenne l'idée de le
remplacer par un système de vote à la
majorité qualifiée pour une partie des
décisions prises jusqu'ici à l'unanimité
sur des domaines précis paraît
inéluctable
surtout si l'union européenne continue
d'accueillir de nouveaux états membres
soyez assurés madame la ministre que
nous resterons très attentifs aux suites
qui pourraient être données à ces sujets
je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues et maintenant le
tour de parole est à manom vernis
guillotin pour le groupe du
rassemblement démocratique social
européen
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues on se souvient une
présidence française de l'union
européenne en 2008 chahuté par une
profonde crise financière
on se souviendra de celle de 2022
focalisé sur la tragédie ukrainienne il
y a un peu plus de six mois la france
avait abordé la présidence de l'union
européenne avec un grand nombre de
projets a porté sur plusieurs fronts
sécuritaire institutionnels climatique
numérique pour le rds profondément
attaché à la construction communautaire
tout cela allait dans le bon sens quel
bilan peut-on dresser aujourd'hui vous
en avez fait le dessin madame la
ministre
et comme vous l'avez expliqué le visage
de l'europe a changé en six mois ce sont
bien souvent des crises qui accélère le
projet européen et qui renforce la
solidarité entre les états membres bien
entendu on ne peut pas totalement se
réjouir de ce constat car s'agissant de
la pandémie et de la guerre en ukraine
le bilan humain est bien trop lourd
néanmoins à l'évidence une des formules
déployés par le président de la
république dans son discours de la
sorbonne en 2010 de 2017 prendra tout se
prend tout son sens aujourd'hui et je le
cite la seule voie qui assure notre
avenir c'est la refondation d'une europe
souveraine unie et démocratique
on doit en effet reconnaître que la
souveraineté de l'europe inscrite à
l'agenda européen de la présidence
française semble prendre corps dans bien
des domaines nous adhérons tout d'abord
au renforcement de la souveraineté
stratégique de l'union européenne une
orientation qui peut tout à fait
s'accommoder avec les engagements que
les états membres ont au sein de l'otan
notre groupe salue les décisions prises
au sommet de versailles le 10 et 11 mars
dernier qui donne un nouvel élan à la
défense européenne toutefois si les
états membres augmentent leurs dépenses
militaires la mise en place de projets
capacitaire commun semble patier
dans un autre domaine la souveraineté
énergétique est devenu brutalement un
enjeu majeur la présidence française a
fait le voeu d'une meilleure
indépendance à l'égard de la russie mais
il revient désormais à la présidence
tchèque de préparer un plan il serait
souhaitable que ce plan ne consiste pas
seulement à gérer la pénurie qui se
profile la question de la formation du
prix du marché de l'électricité ne doit
pas être taboue en outre ce plan de
sécurisation de l'approvisionnement de
l'énergie sera-t-il compatible avec
l'accord sur le climat que la présidence
française a réussi à boucler disons le
le défi énergétique posés par la guerre
en ukraine et la nécessaire transition
écologique pour atteindre la neutralité
carbone en 2050 ne font pas
nécessairement bon ménage je salue en
tout cas le plan climat en particulier
le principe tant attendu de la taxe
carbone aux frontières qui vise à
imposer les normes environnementales de
l'union européenne aux entreprises
étrangères ex portant sur notre
territoire
j'en viens à un autre défi celui de la
souveraineté alimentaire en dehors des
problématiques actuelles liées à
l'ukraine faut-il rappeler ici dans la
chambre des territoires qu'elle passe
par le maintien de nos exploitations
alors que la question des céréales est
au premier plan de l'actualité
l'enjeu agricole semble avoir été
délaissé au cours de ces derniers mois
en outre bruxelles semble parfois
prendre des décisions dans l'impact
financier sur le monde agricole lui
semble secondaire je pense en
particulier à la proposition de révision
de la directive iodé sur les émissions
industrielles qui ajoute dans son champ
d'application certaines activités non
réglementées jusque là ce qui fait que
180 milles 185 mille exploitations de
bovins seraient ainsi concernés contre
vingt mille aujourd'hui pour un coût
estimé à 2400 euros par exploitation et
par an
bien sûr si les exploitations doivent
tout s'orienter vers des pratiques plus
vertueux sur le plan environnemental
elles doivent en retour bénéficier des
soutiens nécessaires à leur conversion
j'en profite pour préciser que ces
soutiens doivent être plus efficaces et
mieux contrôler comme vient de le
souligner le rapport de la cour des
comptes européenne pointant les fraudes
de la pac
mes chers collègues je ne peux pas
épuisé tous les chantiers dont s'est
emparée la présidence française au cours
de ces derniers mois en quelques mots
j'ajoute que le rds applaudi la
directive sur les salaires mines meaux
où les deux lois sur le numérique qui
réglemente la concurrence sur les
grandes plateformes et limite la
diffusion de contenus illicites haineux
ou violents
mais la mesure qui est pas si symbolique
que ça d'imposer un chargeur unique
mesure à la fois de bon sens mesures
économiques mesures écologiques qui
touchent directement les consommateurs
et les citoyens méritent d'être saluées
on ne peut en revanche que regrettait le
véto hongrois brandis sur la taxation
minimale international des entreprises
cet épisode rappelle une fois de plus
l'urgence de passer à la majorité
qualifiée pour certaines décisions c'est
une nécessité si l'europe veut
s'affirmer davantage en tant que
puissance économique
cette question d'ordre institutionnel va
devenir d'autant plus prégnante que se
profilent des perspectives
d'élargissement de l'union européenne à
cet égard la france restera dans les
annales comme le pays qui a ouvert la
porte à l'union europe de l'union
européenne à l'ukraine et à la moldavie
dans ce contexte était bien évidemment
un devoir moral il n'en demeure pas il
n'en demeure pas moins que la relance
d'un potentiel élargissement devra
s'accompagner d'un travail de réflexion
sur les règles de fonctionnement de
l'union européenne d'une part et sur le
concept de communauté politique
européenne lancée par le président de la
république
s'il est de nature notamment à rassurer
les balkans occidentaux il mérite d'être
précisée
enfin vous le savez l'europe du
quotidien se construit aussi et
j'oserais dire de manière un peu
impertinente surtout sur les territoires
transfrontaliers
je ne vous rappelle pas les enjeux de
mon territoire à la frontière avec le
luxembourg sur les questions de
fiscalité de mobilité de santé nous
aurons sur ces sujets à nous revoir les
frontaliers en attendent autant de la
part de l'union européenne que du
gouvernement français nous passons
désormais le flambeau à la tchéquie
souhaitons qu'elles fassent preuve du
même volontarisme que la france pour
affirmer la place de
la france la place de l'europe
peut-être aussi espérons que prague
puisse faire comprendre à certains de
ses partenaires du groupe devise grade
se situe leur intérêt celui d'appartenir
un espace de paix déterminé à le rester
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues le tour de parole
revient maintenant à didier marie pour
le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicaine
[Applaudissements]
chez le président madame la ministre
chers collègues tout d'abord madame la
ministre je vous souhaite la bienvenue
au sénat et vous assure de l'engagement
européen sans faille de mon groupe
madame la ministre nous sortons de six
mois de présidence française du conseil
de l'union européenne et nous restons
quelque peu sur notre faim malgré des
avancées notables sur lesquelles je
reviendrai cette présidence que monsieur
macron voulait exceptionnelle pour
l'europe pour la france et peut-être
aussi pour sa campagne électorale laura
été mais pour une toute autre raison en
effet le 24 février la fédération de
russie déclenché la guerre que certains
n'avaient pas voulu voir venir et
agressé sauvagement l'ukraine
cette nouvelle donne géopolitique a
confirmé comme la crise sanitaire avant
elle la capacité des européens à réagir
rapidement efficacement et en restant
unis peut-être même à la surprise de
nombre d'observateurs extérieurs les
russes les premiers cette situation à
lever les réticences de certains états
membres à l'égard des objectifs
stratégiques d'autonomie et de
souveraineté européenne devenue centraux
et naturel du jour au lendemain le
terrible imprévue de la guerre a joué un
rôle majeur moteur et a permis des
avancées dans de nombreux domaines
paradoxalement monsieur poutine aura
fait plus pour leurs enfants quelques
semaines que les dirigeants européens
n'en avait fait ces dernières années la
solidarité des 27 avec l'ukraine n'a eu
aucune difficulté à s'imposer et s'est
concrétisée par un soutien humanitaire
économique et militaire massif nous
allons à cet égard la décision de
conférer le statut de protection
temporaire aux 4,7 millions de réfugiés
ukrainien tout en s'interrogeant sur les
suites qui seront données si le conflit
s'enlise de même nous nous félicitons de
la mise en oeuvre pour 2 milliards
d'euros de la facilité européenne pour
la paix qui a permis de fournir les
armes défensives nécessaires à la
résistance ukrainienne l'unanimité s'est
aussi rapidement fait pour décider des
six trains successifs de sanctions pour
faire pression sur les dirigeants et
assécher les sources de financement de
l'effort de guerre russes sans
malheureusement que cela ne produisent à
ce jour les effets escomptés de même les
orientations de la boussole stratégie
compte est adopté actant un
réinvestissement militaire mais faute
d'anticipation
elles le sont sous parapluie américain
au sein d'une otan renforcée que le
président de la république qualifiait
pourtant en état de mort cérébrale reste
à savoir qui en sera bénéficiaire la
défense européenne ou seulement les
états unis et leur industrie d'armement
cette recherche de souveraineté
l'autonomie s'est aussi imposé dans le
champ de l'énergie l'europe dépendante
des hydrocarbures russes s'accordant sur
le boycott du charbon et du pétrole mais
échouant malheureusement à se mettre
d'accord sur un embargo du gaz pour le
reste la france alf et pardon excusez
moi la france a fait de travail normale
d'une présidence et a pu faire avancer
les textes législatifs et endossé le
costume de médiateur
au nombre des satisfactions on peut
noter comme vous l'avez fait l'accord
sur le numérique avec l'adoption des
directives dma ds à la réciprocité de
l'accès aux marchés publics dans le
commerce international
l'adoption du salaire minimum l'
équilibre femmes hommes dans les
conseils d'administration des grandes
entreprises ou encore des progrès sur
l'intelligence artificielle
d'autres succès ont été mis en avant
mais en regardant ces accords de plus
près on reste circonspecte je pense au
paquet climat et au fonds social
rétrécie à l'espace schengen sur
les aspects défensifs aux droits sociaux
et à d'autres sujets dont parlera mon
collègue jean yves le conte enfin notons
les échecs en particulier celui relatif
à la texas y ont des grandes entreprises
à hauteur de 15% de leurs bénéfices
celui de la réforme du marché it he is
it est toujours indexé sur le cours du
gaz notons que rien n'a été engagée face
à la menace de stagflation et rien non
plus aucune feuille de route pour un
agenda rural comme le demande la
résolution du sénat initié par mon ami
et collègue patrice joly quelques mots
madame la ministre avant de conclure sur
l'avenir de l'europe nous nous
félicitons que l'ukraine la moldavie est
obtenu le statut de candidat à l'ue eux
et que la géorgie n'est pas été ignoré
nous saluons l'initiative à l'égard des
balkans occidentaux
les rassurant sur leur avenir européen
nous notons avec satisfaction la levée
du veto à l'engagement des négociations
avec la macédoine du nord par le
parlement bulgare même si cela reste à
confirmer
cependant s'il est opportun d'avancer
dans le processus d'élargissement à ces
pays que les pressions extérieures
menace rappelons qu'il ne peut se
réaliser que dans le cadre des accords
de copenhague et tout particulièrement
de la primauté de l'état de droit or à
cet égard l'approbation par la
commission et le conseil du plan de
relance de la pologne sans que toutes
les garanties sur l'indépendance de la
justice n'ait été donnée inquiète
l'unité de l'europe repose certes sur le
dialogue politique mais avant tout sur
le respect de nos valeurs pour ce qui
concerne nos relations avec les pays
candidats et ceux de notre environnement
proche la proposition du président de la
république d'une communauté politique
européenne a reçu un accueil allant du
glacial ou tiède l'avenir sous
présidence tchèque nous dira si cet
objectif européen non identifiés
prospérera pour ma part je m'interroge
son périmètre et sur son contenu plus
largement c'est le fonctionnement même
de l'union qui doit être interrogé et on
ne peut que regretter l'absence de prise
en compte des conclusions de la
conférence sur l'avenir de l'europe et
des appels du parlement européen pour
ouvrir le chantier d'une révision des
traités pour une gouvernance renouvelée
de l'union où les citoyens auraient tous
leur rôle à jouer madame la ministre la
france a rempli sa mission et il
convient de féliciter les diplomates qui
ont travaillé mais cette présidence est
terminé assez loin des slogans
enthousiastes du président ma croûte
décembre 2021 puissance relance
appartenance le président parle beaucoup
d'europe ne manque pas d'idées mais il
ya encore loin des paroles aux actes
cette présidence en demi-teinte aura
plus été porté par les événements
canalisera provoquer et elle restera
malheureusement dans l'histoire comme
celle qui aura la vue la guerre revenu
sur notre continent ces six mois nous
aurons aussi rappelé que l'europe est un
collectif forgé par la culture du
dialogue politique la recherche du
consensus et une action résolue fondées
sur nos valeurs liberté démocratie et
justice sociale responsabilités
environnementales merci
la parole est maintenant un
jean-baptiste lemoyne pour le groupe
rassemblement démocrate progressiste et
indépendant
monsieur le président monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
européennes mesdames les ministres mes
chers collègues six petits mois et déjà
l'union européenne n'est plus ce qu'elle
était avant 2022 alors il s'agit pas de
lancer un cocorico cocardier pour se
faire plaisir mais je constate que notre
union européenne a beaucoup progressé et
par gros temps cette présidence
française du conseil de l'union
européenne elle marque aussi
l'aboutissement d'un certain nombre
d'initiatives lancées auparavant par le
président de la république dès 2017 on
se souvient sur ses bancs du discours de
la sorbonne pour une europe plus
souveraine plus protectrice et puis elle
marque aussi l'arrivée à bon port de
chantiers lancés ou suivis par de
précédentes présidences c'est là le
joueur monieux de ces passage de
flambeau d'un état membre à l'autre
chaque semestre et dire que certains
recommandait que la france passe son
tour pour cause d'élection
présidentielle comme le rappelait andré
gattolin mais je veux dire au président
rappaz que en 95 déjà la france préside
a alors que des échéances
présidentielles importantes avaient lieu
alors oui le calendrier des événements a
été très ramassé mais le plus important
c'est le fond la substance que le conti
soi et que des projets majeurs est été
enregistré et bien ce succès je reprends
le terme de madame la ministre
historique eh bien il revient bien au
président la république épaules et bien
sûr de l'ensemble de ses ministres de
vous-même mesdames les ministres de vos
prédécesseurs jean yves le drian clément
bonne secrétaire général de la
présidence française je pense à toutes
les équipes animées par xavier la paire
de cabane à notre représentation
permanente naturellement sous l'égide de
philippe léglise qu'au stade du sg eu de
l'ensemble des agents mobilisés au quai
d'orsay dans les autres ministères de
notre autre assemblée aussi vous l'avez
rappelé président
sans oublier les collectivités locales
qui ont mis beaucoup d'engagement et de
coeur dans l'accueil des événements je
peux en témoigner à titre personnel pour
les mères des bonnes villes de pau de
dijon cher françois patriat ou de
montpellier sans oublier strasbourg plus
que jamais capitale européenne cher
ludovic est alors relance puissance
appartenance était le triptyque de cette
présidence est en effet si elle a
commencé sous le signe de la relance
post vide on l'a vu très vite
l'agression russe sur le sol
l'ukraine le retour de la guerre sur le
sol européen et bien en fait que les
termes de puissance et d'appartenance
ont été au coeur de l'action conduite
par cette présidence française et en
europe et un seul a rejoint le fil rouge
que le tir le président république
depuis 2010 est celui d'une souveraineté
d'une indépendance européenne accrue etc
l'idée tout simplement que nous
reprenions le contrôle en européen et
non pas comme ça a été tentée de l'autre
côté de la manche en solitaire et que en
européen nous ne soyons pas des objets
de l'histoire qui s'écrit mais que nous
soyons bien des sujets dits maîtrisons
notre propre destin et notre avenir
alors tout cela cette présidence
s'inscrit dans un contexte mondial
marqué naturellement par ce conflit en
ukraine par également on le voit dans
l'environnement mondial le barycentre
qui se déplace vers le pacifique sur
fond de rivalité sino-américaine et puis
par l'urgence climatique qui taraude
naturellement encore et toujours nos
sociétés et bien tout au long de cette
présidence française l'union européenne
ses états membres se sont affirmés en
tant que puissance politique et
géopolitique j'en veux pour preuve
l'adoption de la boussole stratégique
qui crée cette culture stratégique
commune le renforcement des capacités de
déploiement rapide de force le
renforcement des investissements de
défense acté lors du sommet de
versailles également une meilleure tenue
de nos frontières externes avec la
création du conseil schengen qui s'est
déjà réuni deux fois et qui permettra je
crois d'aller toujours plus loin en la
matière en termes de coordination et
puis dans ce monde marqué par le retour
des empires en quelque sorte et bien
l'europe se pense et se projette dans
toute sa vaste dimension je pense
naturellement aux outre mer c'est michel
dennemont aux régions ultrapériphériques
qui font de l'europe est bien un
continent monde et qui fait que nous
avons un mot à dire une voix
particulière effectivement dans ce
concert mondial alors que de chemin
parcouru depuis la chute du mur de
berlin depuis la réunification de
l'europe de l'ouest et de l'europe de
l'est est désormais c'est la poursuite
de l'unification du continent européen
qui est en marche je ne peux m'empêcher
de penser à l'un des penseurs de cette
europe denis de rougemont qui 10 l
europe unie n'est pas un expédient
moderne économico-politique un idéal
qu'approuve depuis mille ans les
meilleurs esprits ce qu'ils ont vu loin
les européens madame la ministre la
présidence française mais dans les miss
ont vu loin en effet le statut de
candidat à l'adhésion ainsi été accordés
par les vingt-sept à l'ukraine à la
moldavie vous l'avez rappelé c'était
quelques jours après que à kiev et vous
étiez aux côtés du président de la
république
déjà ces mots d'encouragement été
prononcée dans un délai particulièrement
rapide quel temps cela prendra nul ne
peut le dire mais le cap est fixé
c'est le plus important et nous
n'oublions pas l'importance des balkans
occidentaux vous l'avez rappelé je le
sais cher également au président richard
et comme la géographie commandes que
seuls 14 petits kilomètres sépare
l'europe de l'afrique nous pouvons
également et bien être fiers du
partenariat renouvelé avec le continent
africain avec ce sommet de bruxelles en
février qui a permis d'aller de l'avant
en matière de sécurité d'environnement
de santé de migration et puis au delà
avec l'ensemble de nos partenaires nous
avons un certain nombre de défis globaux
mondiaux a relevé et très clairement
soit on y arrive ensemble si on échoue
ensemble donc on n'a pas le choix et ça
veut dire par exemple en matière de
lutte contre le changement climatique
est bien d'être aux avant-postes et par
nos propres réglementations aussi de
faire évoluer les réglementations des
autres ensembles dans le monde et de ce
point de vue là cette taxe carbone aux
frontières je suis persuadé et bien qu
elle influera sur les réglementations
dont se doteront nos partenaires
reprendre le contrôle disait ge en
termes politiques géopolitiques mais
également en termes économiques
énergétiques industrielles commerciales
l'europe à commencer par la construction
économique qui serait absurde que voilà
aujourd'hui en 2022 elle se fasse dicter
sa loi en la matière tels renonçait une
puissance économique et donc c'est très
important de forger nos propres stands
ya d'ar de ne pas être les idiots utiles
du village global et de ce point de vue
là le fait d'avoir des grands projets
industriels européens on pense aux
batteries et on en a enclenché de
nouveau sous cette présidence française
en matière de santé le fait que nous
développions notre indépendance
énergétique alimentaire le fait que en
matière commerciale ne soyons pas
également les naïfs mais que nous ayons
de nouvelles l'ex éclosent miroir avec
également l'instrument de réciprocité
sur les marchés publics qui met de la de
l'équité dans la concurrence eh bien
nous avons progressé et je peux vous
dire que longtemps on nous regardait de
travers à bruxelles est bien là les
résultats sont là et puis
être reprendre le contrôle c'est
également tout simplement s'armer face
aux géants du numérique c'est se
prémunir de pratiques déloyales et de ce
point de vue là l'acte sur les services
numériques l'acte sur les marchés
numériques et bien permettront justement
d'encadrer les activités de réguler et
c'est donc un bilan fourni et bien qui
s'appuie sur le respect tant de l'unité
européenne que de sa diversité on sait
c'est notre maxime notre devise
européenne et la présidence française
l'a illustré de fort belle manière
l'unité d'abord qui a été préservé dans
toutes les prises de décision et vous
l'avez rappelé la ministre avec six
trains de sanctions et puis la diversité
donc je note aussi qu' arrêter
d'ailleurs revendiqué par l'ambassadeur
de république tchèque s'exprimant devant
notre assemblée et c'est vrai que nous
avons voulu une présidence en langue
française une présidence qui respecte le
plurilinguisme de nombreuses actions ont
été conduites à la suite du rapport de
christian lequesne elles doivent être
poursuivis nous partons de loin de très
loin ils ont besoin madame la ministre
de tout votre volontarisme politique
pour que ces efforts soient appuyés dans
la durée c'est donc un très bon bilan
que le groupe r des pays salut qui est à
l'honneur et au crédit de la france nous
avons pour autant qu'il reste en tête en
affaires que tous nos meilleurs voeux
vous accompagne madame la ministre ainsi
que l'actuelle présidence tchèque et la
future présidence suédoise je vous
remercie
et la parole est au président claude
mêlerait pour le groupe des indépendants
je le président madame la ministre
mesdames les ministres monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
européennes et chers collègues
concomitante d'élections présidentielle
et législatives la présidence française
du conseil de l'union européenne avait
tout pour échouer comme beaucoup ne
s'était pas privé de le faire remarquer
au point d'en demander le report au
terme de l'exercice ou sous la faune der
leyen président de la commission
européenne juge le résultat je site
exceptionnel les chancelleries et
l'ensemble de la presse sont du même
avis même si l'air du temps et au
dénigrement systématique de toute action
politique
il n'y a aucune raison de ne pas le dire
clairement la pf et s'achève par un
succès
nos diplomates qu'il faut saluer et le
gouvernement ont imprimé un rythme
effréné à bruxelles capitale des
compromis déséquilibres et des décisions
chronophage même si quelques rares
dossiers manquent à l'appel des accords
majeurs en en forger le bilan positif
les priorités étaient claires climat
numérique et sociale la directive sur
les salaires minimums coeur de cible de
ces urgences a été atteint quant au
climat à l'arraché dans les tous
derniers jours la france a su composer
et trouver des terrains d'entente pour
réduire collectivement nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre la vision de mon
groupe est celle d'une écologie libérale
de progrès et d'innovation le travail
effectué sur la sobriété énergétique et
les réponses industriels associés seront
des atouts importants de demain je salue
particulièrement des avancées sur le
mécanisme d'ajustement carbone aux
frontières
exemple de l'alliance entre le
développement économique et les
ambitions climatiques
enfin le numérique je partage ce cas
très justement exprimé le commissaire
thierry breton tout ce qui est interdit
aux flammes doit l'être online la
régulation ne vous l'avais dit tout à
l'heure madame la ministre la régulation
des grandes plateformes numériques est
capitale pour nos entreprises mais
surtout pour nos citoyens les réseaux
anti sociaux sont un far west où se
développent complotisme et m2 l'autre
c'est un écosystème de fait que new
skies abine nos démocraties et mai
jeunes et moins jeunes à la merci du
cyber harcèlement
réguler les contenus avec le ds à
encadrer les pratiques commerciales avec
le dma sur les meilleurs moyens de
maîtriser notre espace européen je fais
le voeu que ce texte soit applicable dès
la fin de l'année et que l'on continue
sans relâche à travailler sur ces sujets
la performance de ces six derniers mois
est d'autant plus appréciable que cette
présidence a été percuté de plein fouet
le 24 février par la guerre en ukraine
l'idée de réorienter les priorités ayant
été à juste titre écarté tout a dû être
menées de front la sale guerre de
poutine a donc été la toile de fond des
deux tiers de la présidence française
elle aurait pu faire voler l'union en
éclats elle n'a fait paradoxalement que
la renforcer
poutine voulait diviser l'europe il l'a
cimente ridiculiser le temps il l'a
retrempe humilié les états unis il
ressuscite byden après le revers de
kaboul rallier à lui les régimes
autoritaires la chine s'inquiète la
turquie montre le dans le kazakhstan
refusé l'envoi de ses soldats il pensait
prendre l'ukraine en trois jours il est
embourbé pour longtemps le principal
succès français et il faut y associer la
présidente de la commission a été dans
des circonstances difficiles avec
certains partenaires à la limite du
chantage de parvenir à maintenir l'unité
des vingt-sept de décider de sanctions
communes de réunir une aide militaire et
humanitaire efficace à l'ukraine et
enfin de renforcer la cohésion avec les
états unis et l'ensemble des démocraties
la prochaine étape sera plus difficile
poutine le sait il l'attend et il
l'espère elle consiste à relever le défi
du long terme
quand la guerre va peu à peu affecté
l'économie aggravé l'inflation et le
coût de la vie augmente et les dépenses
d'énergie
le défi sera de tenir face aux opinions
publiques
quand la mauvaise petite musique bien
sûr renforcé par tous les trolls les
bottes et les trash médias de la
cinquième colonne des lots peine d amour
et d mêlant chant viendra susurré que la
guerre coûte trop cher et que tout n'est
pas noir et blanc eq après tout ce n'est
pas notre guerre alors que bien sûr elle
les seuls les naïfs ou des agentes des
informations peuvent croire le contraire
poutine vient enfin d'avouer lors de la
célébration du 350e anniversaire de
pierre legrand que la guerre en ukraine
n'a rien à voir avec la supposée menace
occidentale que dénonce depuis des
années ses affidés il apporte lui même
la réponse claire et définitive à tous
les idiots utiles qui répètent depuis
des mois que la russie n'a fait que
répondre aux menaces de l'europe et de
l'otan je cite l'ukraine fait partie de
la propre histoire de la culture et de
l'espace spirituel de la russie après
pierre le grand et je cite encore c'est
maintenant notre tour de reprendre et
renforcer ce qui appartient à la russie
la guerre en ukraine n'est rien d'autre
qu'une tentative d'annexion est nos
nationalistes comme en témoigne depuis
deux jours la délivrance de passeports
russes aux ukrainiens et c'est le
fauteur lui même de cette guerre qui
vient de l'annoncer le masque est tombé
la guerre vient enfin d'apporter de
l'eau au moulin du président de la
république qui ne cesse depuis cinq ans
de plaider en prêchant jusqu alors dans
le désert pour l'europe puissance c'est
là encore un des plus grands échecs de
poutine avoir ouvert les yeux à des
centaines de millions d'européens qui
croyaient que la guerre était une
relique du passé et qu'ils étaient
parvenus à la paix perpétuelle de quand
alors qu'il n'était qu' en train de
préparer leur sortie l'histoire l'europe
s'est engagée dans son réarmement et
adopté sans ciller la boussole
stratégique proposé par emmanuel macron
espérons que cette leçon sera retenue
plus longtemps que toutes celles qui
disparaissent au gré d'une actualité qui
ne fait plus qu exacerber les émotions
et s'évanouir la mémoire il reste que
l'union devra se garder de céder à la
tentation d'un gaullisme du pauvre qui
n'a rien à voir avec le gaullisme et qui
conduirait à prêcher la médiation voir
l'équidistance entre amérique et russie
demain entre amérique et chine sans
comprendre qu'il ya d'un côté le camp de
la démocratie et de l'autre celui des
dictatures
cette nouvelle guerre froide avec un art
verse un adversaire chinois
à terme beaucoup plus puissants et
inquiétant que ne l'était l'union
soviétique sera avec le climat la menace
majeure pour les générations à venir
contrairement à ce que prétendent les
tyranneaux fils d'extrême droite et
d'extrême gauche ce ne sont pas les
démocraties qui en sont à l'origine mais
les dictatures et les systèmes
totalitaires qui portent en eux la
guerre comme la nuée porte l'orage
prétendre échapper à ce cadre
géostratégique où il y occupait une
position de neutralité comme une sorte
de grande suisse qui fut trop longtemps
la tentation des européens serait une
erreur même le jour lointain où nous
serons enfin réarmer mais ce serait
aujourd'hui tout bonnement une
incompréhension totale des rapports de
force la boussole stratégique et
bienvenue elle ne se conçoit que dans
une alliance toujours plus étroite avec
les démocraties extra européenne et un
rôle toujours aussi fondamental de
l'otan
la réussite de la présidence française
du conseil de l'union européenne ne lève
pas tous les doutes bien sûr
l'avenir de l'union est problématique
les nouveaux clivages politiques se
dessine désormais entre pro européen et
populiste l'avenir de l'europe est
toujours fragile car elle continue de
vivre sous un régime perpétuelle de
crise les blocages institutionnels
persiste nous avons dû faire face à un
brésil qui nous hante même après le
départ du prime minister d'huguette
brookside d'un nous vivons avec la
guerre en europe à nos portes et une
crise sanitaire qui n'est pas terminée
dans son en plus en plus compliqué nos
valeurs sont menacés de l'extérieur et
hélas de l'intérieur la conférence sur
l'avenir de l'europe n'a pas eu l'élan
escompté est pour l'heure la refondation
des traités européens semble bien
compliqué mais je suis certain que le
désir d'europe sera plus fort que tout
comme l'espérait dans son essai europa
valéry giscard d'estaing lorsqu ils nous
demandaient de réussir à réaliser le
rêve européen je vous remercie
la parole est à monsieur alain cadec
pour le groupe des républicains
madame la ministre chers collègues
mon analyse va différer un peu de sel de
notre collègue malhuret mais ça ne vous
surprendra pas
le fait pour la france d'occuper la
présidence tournante et semestrielle du
conseil de l'union européenne est un
événement d'autant plus notable qu'il
est peu fréquent on se souvient en effet
que la dernière présidence française
remonte à 2008 dans un contexte qui
était déjà un contexte de crise
rappelons au passage que la présidence
du conseil de l'union européenne
coïncidait à l'époque avec celle du
conseil européen elle réunissait les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement ce qui
conférait à nicolas sarkozy à l'époque
pendant le semestre concerné la qualité
de président de cette dernière
institution tel n'est plus le cas
aujourd'hui depuis le traité lisbonne le
conseil européen dispose désormais d'une
présidence permanente
actuellement assurée par le belge
charles michel et ce n'est que par abus
de langage ou facilité journalistique
qu'on a pu souvent présenté emmanuel
macron comme président du conseil
européen voire sans crainte de l'emphase
comme président de l'europe
il importe également de rappeler la
nature véritable de cette présidence du
conseil de l'union européenne elle
confie essentiellement aux ministres
concernés un rôle d'animation de
modération et le cas échéant de bons
offices pour dégager
tu es et fixer la position du conseil en
vue de négociations avec le parlement
qui dans la plupart des matières & co
législateur
c'est un rôle important certes mais
c'est de ne pas un rôle décisionnel
le document de synthèse du bilan de la
présidence française que j'ai consultés
en préparation de ce débat me semble
faire un peu fi de ces réalités
institutionnelles et marquées au coin de
la forfanterie voire de l'exagération
il présente en effet les décisions
prises par le conseil européen notamment
en réaction à l'agression de l'ukraine
comme lié à cette présidence voir
orchestrée par celle-ci or comme je
viens de l'expliquer il n'en est rien
par ailleurs il met au crédit de
l'action de la france l'ensemble des
avancées législatives réalisés pendant
le premier semestre de cette année avec
une liste impressionnante de cases
cochées fait fait fait comme autant de
mission accomplie or cette liste ne
comporte aucun dossier traité de bout en
bout par cette présidence certains des
dossiers concernés ont pu être mené à
terme sur la base d'un travail au
conseil déjà bien engagée sous la
présidence précédente d'autres ne sont
pas encore conclu et les négociations
interinstitutionnelle à leur sujet se
poursuivent aujourd'hui sous présidence
tchèque
nous représentants aux conseils appuyés
par d'excellents fonctionnaires à paris
et au sein de la représentation
permanente à bruxelles ont certes fait
du très bon travail il ya de véritables
succès parmi lesquels je salue
particulièrement l'adoption du règlement
ds à et dma en matière numérique
l'adoption de l'instrument de
réciprocité sur les marchés publics
chimie et des avancées importantes en
vue de l'adoption d'un mécanisme
d'ajustement carbone aux frontières
il ya cependant certains raccourcis
audacieux pour ne pas parler de contre
vérités que je ne peux m'empêcher de
relever je ne mentionnerai que deux non
madame la ministre la france n'est pas
parvenue à favoriser la mise en place de
normes de production identique pour les
produits fabriqués dans l'union
européenne et les produits importés le
fameux concept de klose miroir concocté
à paris pour l'occasion est considéré
par la plupart des experts
comme bancal et contestable du point de
vue du nc il n'a reçu de nos partenaires
européens qu'un accueil poli pour ne pas
dire froid et un rapport récent de la
commission européenne sur le sujet
incite à ne pas avoir d attente trop
importante pour ce qui concerne sa mise
en oeuvre concrète
non madame la ministre la politique
commerciale n'a pas été réorientés sous
l'impulsion de la france afin notamment
de renforcer ses exigences
environnementales et sociales dans les
accords commerciaux
la volonté de procéder à un tel
renforcement est affichée par la
commission européenne depuis des années
le rapport longtemps attendu qu'elle
vient de publier sur le sujet va
d'ailleurs dans ce sens sa lecture
attentive révèle toutefois que des
sanctions commerciales pour non respect
de ces exigences par nos partenaires ne
pourront être envisagées quant au
dernier ressort suivant des conditions
très difficiles à réunir et au terme de
procédures lourdes et complexes de plus
ceux-ci ne concernera que les accords
commerciaux futur et pas ceux qui ont
déjà été conclus ou sont en attente de
conclusion je pense en particulier au
mercosur
l'épreuve les progrès réels sont donc
très limité de manière plus générale la
question des accords commerciaux pose
problème
tout le monde convient que la france est
parvenue sous sa présidence à bloquer la
conclusion de certains accords dont acte
il est toutefois devenu clair au fil des
mois que la commission et la dg trade
ainsi que le groupe des états membres
les plus libres échangistes de l'union
européenne attendait simplement l'erreur
l'annnonce de la conclusion d'un accord
de libre échange avec la
nouvelle-zélande est dramatique pour
notre agriculture
elle a été faite en grandes pompes par
la présidente de la commission
européenne et la première ministre de la
nouvelle zélande le 1er juillet c'est à
dire dès le lendemain de la fin de la
présidence française mieux encore la
nouvelle présidence tchèque du conseil
de l'union européenne à inscrire la
relance de l'agenda européen des
négociations commerciales en tête de ses
priorités pour le semestre au titre de
la concurrence économique internationale
la présidence française n'aura pas non
plus été créés en capacité de lever tous
les blocages sur la taxation minimale
des multinationales et de convaincre la
hongrie de se joindre au consensus
européen
nous sommes donc ici réduit
littéralement à espérer que le
gouvernement américain qui entend
dénoncer la convention fiscale qui le
lie à budapest sera plus efficace sur le
sujet que la présidence française
ceci illustre selon moi tout leur la
relativité des pouvoirs qui découle
d'une telle présidence alors les auto
congratulation sur les réalisations de
la présidence française ne serait en
effet nous faire oublier que l'europe si
elle semble désormais avoir davantage
conscience d'elle-même de ses intérêts
et de la réalité du monde est à la
croisée des chemins
comme je les dis la france a sans doute
fait du bon travail et n'a pas à rougir
de son bilan cependant madame la
ministre un peu de modestie aurait sans
doute été plus raisonnable dans la
présentation de ce bilan il est vrai que
l'humilité n'est pas la qualité première
de notre président je vous remercie
la parole maintenant à monsieur jacques
fernique pour le groupe écologie
solidarité et territoires
le président madame la ministre chers
collègues ses six mois de présidence
française du conseil de notre union
européenne ont effectivement était
lourdement marquée par un tragique
imprévu la guerre russes contre
l'ukraine n'est pas seulement la tacc
contre un pays souverain contre un
peuple courageux qui défend ses droits
sa liberté sa démocratie elle est aussi
le plus grand défi à la sécurité commune
en europe depuis mai 45 une attaque
délibérée contre les principes et le
mécanisme de coopération et de sécurité
en europe
la réponse solidaire et déterminé de
l'union européenne a pu surprendre ceux
qui misaient sur son inertie et sa
mollesse elle se traduit compterait
concrètement par des sanctions de l'aide
militaire financière et humanitaire cet
imprévu tragique a sans doute contribué
à renforcer l'esprit de consensus qui
marque le bilan de ce semestre oui tant
avec le conseil qu avec le parlement de
nombreuses avancées ont été enregistrées
pour autant il ne faudrait pas
maintenant la ministre que ce débat
d'évaluation sans vote auquel le
gouvernement nous invite dans les deux
chambres au titre de l'article 50 se
tirer 1 de la constitution il ne
faudrait pas que ce débat gomme les
aspérités problématique les blocages ou
les régressions parfois les sujets sur
lesquels on peut peiner encore à
discerner de franchise orientations
européennes
d'abord je voudrais déploré les
insatisfactions comparé moment provoquer
des absences notables de ministres
français nous savions que la collusion
notre calendrier électoral national avec
l'agenda de la présidence française
pourrait poser problème
la place laissée vide par des ministres
français lors de certains débats
thématiques au parlement européen
concernant directement la pf yeux sur
des chantiers majeurs la question l'état
de droit par exemple a produit un effet
regrettable au moment où justement les
gouvernements hongrois ou pologne et
tente de profiter de la forte tension
internationale pour que ces mouches
notre vigilance sur la pratique de
l'état de droit dont le président de la
république dit pourtant qu'il est notre
trésor fondé pour reprendre ses termes
sur nos valeurs d'européens qui font
notre unité notre fierté notre force par
contre avec l'accord sur le paquet
climat
juste avant de passer la main notre pays
a joué incontestablement un rôle positif
pour faire avancer les dispositifs
correspondant au rehaussement de
l'ambition climatique européenne
si on peut relever que les objectifs de
1032 progression des renouvelables ou de
l'efficacité énergétique ne sont pas
encore assez dans la trajectoire d un
degré et demi des accords de paris il
faut surtout dire qu'au delà de
l'affichage d'objectifs le plus
compliqué reste à faire faire bifurquer
en conséquence les politiques publiques
avec par exemple la fin des subventions
aux fossiles la suppression des quotas
gratuits des grands émetteurs
industriels qui ne peut traîner
indéfiniment
faire en sorte que les territoires comme
le sénat le demande à chaque occasion
puisse avoir les moyens de décliner
efficacement ses politiques climatiques
particulièrement sur les enjeux
d'adaptation je voudrais dire combien
mon groupe déplore que la france n'est
pas appuyé la proposition du parlement
européen pour que les ménages soient
exclus du marché carbone des transports
routiers et du chauffage des bâtiments
dire aussi combien mon groupe s'inquiète
du rétrécissement du fonds social pour
le climat nous savons l'importance
décisive des dispositifs
d'accompagnement de réduction des
inégalités sociales et territoriales
face à ces transitions la gestion
difficile des conséquences énergétique
de la guerre en ukraine avec le
renchérissement des coûts pourrait être
l'occasion de hâter la sortie nécessaire
du notre dépendance aux énergies
fossiles ce n'est pas l'orientation
claire qui se dégage des décisions
européennes il le récent du tout il
aurait sans doute fallu pour répondre à
la hausse des prix d'énergie reprendre
la proposition de la commission
européenne de taxer les super profits
des multinationales de l'énergie
la fin à présent programme et des
voitures thermiques neuf pour 2035 nous
oblige à déployer enfin massivement les
stratégies industrielles d'innovation de
reconversion et de formation stratégie
seul à même d'éviter le désastre social
et économique annoncée si nous
n'anticipons pas si nous n'entendons que
ceux qui s'obstinent à chercher à
maintenir le plus longtemps possible
un modèle industriel dépassé c'est à mon
sens d'ailleurs un même état d'esprit
dépassée qui a hélas permis au tenant du
gaz fossile et à ceux du nucléaire
d'obtenir un vote très politique et si
peu scientifique pour labelliser durable
ses énergies dans le référentiel pour la
finance verte la fameuse taxonomie qui
va perdre de ce fait une bonne part de
sa crédibilité
si le pacte vert et les ambitions
européennes pour le climat et la
biodiversité ont besoin du levier de la
finance ils ont également besoin du
levier décisif des pratiques agricoles
la présidence française n'a guère fait
preuve de volontarisme pour actionner ce
levier bien au contraire notre
gouvernement s'évertue toujours à
obtenir une déclinaison nationale à la
carte de la politique agricole commune
dans le contexte du drame ukrainien il
pèse pour que soit raboté les ambitions
environnementales de la stratégie
européenne pour l'agriculture cette
question-là entendu tout à l'heure
encore a fait débat au sein de notre
sénat certes la résolution européenne de
la majorité va dans votre sens c'est
pour mon groupe une fausse route sur
l'accord commercial avec la nouvelle
zélande non on n'est pas encore dans la
nouvelle génération annoncé des accords
commerciaux vertueux pour les normes
environnementales le compte n'y est pas
si la directive sur le salaire minimum a
bien été gérée dans les temps et
permettra par ce cadre commun de lutter
un peu mieux contre le dumping social
mon groupe déplore par contre le rôle de
la france sur les travailleurs des
plateformes l'actualité toute récente
avec l'en-tête du monde et de ses
partenaires a mis en évidence la
nécessité d'une loi de séparation des
lobbys et de l'état pour la
reconnaissance du salariat d aubert ou
autres des livres ou pour l'inversion de
la charge de la preuve la france est
elle vraiment dans le bon sens en europe
non pour reprendre l'expression notre
collègue olivier jacquin elle freine
plutôt des deux pieds pour conclure
cette appréciation des six mois de
présidence française je voudrais
insister sur trois enjeux déterminants
pour lesquelles l'action de notre
gouvernement n'a manifestement pas
permis de progresser l'enjeu budgétaire
d'abord beaucoup savent qu'il serait
contreproductif de revenir aux règles
budgétaires que romano prodi qualifié de
stupide et que ces années qu'ovide ont
achevé de disqualifier qui envisagerait
sérieusement de pouvoir mener les
investissements de la décarbonation et
de l'adaptation dans le carcan du pacte
de stabilité
le président de la république
envisageait une réforme significative de
ces fameux critères où en est elle
l'enjeu des ressources propres ensuite
nous savons que l'emprunt commun de la
relance s'appuie sur une série de
ressources propres à mettre en place
plus que d'autres états membres la
france avait sans doute la carrure pour
faire avancer concrètement ces mises en
place l'union européenne aurait ainsi pu
être la première à entériner le projet
de taxe sur les multinationales
résultant de l'accord de l'acte de l'
ocde l'échec face au blocage hongrois
vient hélas renforcer l'impression qu'on
traîne encore et toujours sur ses
ressources propres pourtant
indispensable si on ne veut pas que le
remboursement futur de la dette
européenne se fasse au détriment des
programmes européens et du budget
existant enfin la conférence sur
l'avenir de l'europe et la façon dont
des citoyens et des forces vives qui
sont investis oblige même si elle n'a
pas eu tout à fait l'écho populaire visé
oblige à sortir du statu quo à bouger
pour plus et mieux d'europe à l'issue de
la présidence française les conditions
sont-elles en place pour que les
responsables européens engagent des
réponses adaptées à la hauteur de
recommandations à la hauteur des
suggestions de la conférence ci
nécessite de modifier le cadre fixé par
les traités voilà voilà dans ces
quelques minutes notre contribution à ce
débat sur cette psf yeux si elle vous
semble manquer de mesures en pointant
davantage des intertitres faction c'est
parce qu'elle est portée soyez en
assurés par des aspirations forte au
renforcement européen
merci chers collègues aient maintenant
la parole et à jean yves le conte pour
le groupe socialiste écologistes et
républicains
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le président que sa vue me
semble-t-il votre première présence au
plateau madame la ministre je salue
aussi votre présence première présence
dans l'hémicycle mes chers collègues
la présidence française de l'union
européenne ce n'est pas la présidence de
l'europe par le chef de l'état français
mais un rôle de catalyseur pour faire
avancer par le conseil européen sur les
propositions de la commission
arrivant en première partie de l'année
2022 il est un peu il était important de
faire avancer un certain nombre de
dossiers pour que finalement des
trilogues puisse aboutir avant la fin du
mandat du parlement européen et de la
commission c'est donc l'intérêt d'avoir
à la présidence un pays qui a une
administration qui sait être efficace et
mobiliser comme elle l'a été
effectivement pendant ces six mois
c'est la clé pour obtenir sur des sujets
qui sont souvent techniques des accords
ou des avancées toutefois manqué aussi
la partie la parti politique bien
entendu nous avons été totalement
percuté choquée par l'agression russe
contre l'ukraine qui n'est pas qu'un
évènement majeur qui a obligé à s'unir
pour faire pour prendre des sanctions
contre la russie pour accélérer des
élargissements pour accueillir les
réfugiés qui venait d'ukraine et pour
actionner une facilité européenne tour
de la défense pour accompagner et les
forces armées ukrainiennes mais cette
agression grave mais aussi en cause
plusieurs de nos fondamentaux si nous
concernant nous parlons d'abord du
climat
défi climatique qui à lui seul justifie
le renforcement de toutes nos politiques
européennes et plus de solidarité
européenne le paquet fit fauves tf6
lille-fives bon il a un peu avancé mais
pas beaucoup la fin des quotas gratuits
a été repoussée pour permettre
l'adoption de mécanismes d'ajustement
carbone aux frontières mais la question
de l'accompagnement de la compétitivité
de nos entreprises à l'export n'est pas
encore totalement traité toutefois au
regard de la grille de la guerre en
ukraine la question de la taxonomie est
de la place du gaz dans celle ci
apparaît comme totalement anachronique
par rapport à l'obligation est la
nécessité de renforcer notre
indépendance énergétique mais aussi par
rapport à ce que veut dire la guerre en
ukraine dont la remise en cause
finalement du modèle de développement
européen et en particulier du modèle de
développement allemand avec le gaz russe
depuis plus de plus de 20 ans est un
fondamental un fondamental de
l'allemagne un fondamental de l'union
européenne qui est ainsi remis en cause
je pense aussi aux effets de la crise
alimentaire et à la manière dont la pac
devra y répondre concernant les
questions d'asile des migrations la
proche finalement assez technique
graduelle pour essayer de faire avancer
le le pacte asile et migrations proposé
en 2020 par la commission européenne
obtenu des petites avancées mais plutôt
sur des textes répressifs je pense alors
au dac même si la petite avancée qui
permet d'intégrer les personnes qui
débarquent de sauvetage en mer pas comme
des personnes qui arrivent et qui
franchissent de manière illégale mais de
manière spécifique comme personnes qui
viennent d'un sauvetage en mer est une
avancée qui a permis en particulier à
l'espagne d'accepter cette évolution le
règlement filtrage sur lequel le
parlement européen aura encore beaucoup
à dire enfin la déclaration de
solidarité reste encore très faible
puisque finalement les les pays qui
l'ont signée s'engage aujourd'hui à à
peu près 8000 recueil relocalisation ce
qui ne représente pas énormément par
rapport aux besoins et d'ailleurs
finalement les désaccords qui ont été
obtenues ces deux textes restent à
valider par le parlement européen et
nous savons combien un certain nombre de
pays sont plus sur la ligne du parlement
européen était initialement sur la ligne
par leur bien et continue à espérer que
le parlement européen fera évoluer les
acquis actuels de les accords obtenus
actuellement il faut aussi espérer
madame la ministre que la la le fait
d'avoir
mis en oeuvre la protection temporaire
pour la première fois pour les réfugiés
en provenance d'ukraine remettra en
cause certains de nos fondamentaux en
matière de politique d'asile pour la
première fois les personnes qui viennent
demander la protection en europe ont la
liberté de circulation et ont
immédiatement le droit au travail ces
deux remarques mérite des prises en
compte probablement pour faire évoluer
la manière dont nous abordons notre
politique d'asile en europe il faudra en
tirer tous les enseignements et ne pas
simplement dire qu'il s'agit d'une
exception qu il se reproduira jamais
c'est important pour l'efficacité de
notre politique d'asile je pense aussi
à ceux
l'ukraine paie le prix fort depuis 2014
parce qu'elle a choisi la voie
européenne les pays des balkans
choisissent la voie européenne depuis
longtemps et l'élargissement n'avance
pas il est
heureux ben si c'est malheureusement
dans un contexte particulièrement
tragique que nous ayons pu au cours de
cette présidence affirmé la camp d'al le
droit et la candidature à l'union
européenne de la moldavie et l'ukraine
ait pu dynamiser la candidature de
plusieurs pays des balkans occidentaux
ma conviction passe par le fait que
cette c'est absolument nécessaire de
pouvoir aujourd'hui pour renforcer
l'esprit européen de pouvoir répondre à
ces peuples qui demandent et qui
considèrent l'union européenne comme le
projet leurs projets le projet de leur
population pour arriver à mieux se
développer et améliorer leur gouvernance
mais j'ai deux inquiétudes madame la
ministre la première sur l'état de droit
la deuxième sur l'économie européenne
pour avoir un pour tenter d'avoir un
accord sur la fiscalité minimum sur les
multinationales
des concessions ont été faites à la
pologne
madame la ministre il n'est pas possible
de transiger sur l'état de droit il
n'est pas possible de faire
taxation contre plan de relance sans
regarder la manière dont la justice
fonctionne dans ces pays dans des pays
qui refusent le parquet européen et qui
ne disposent pas d'une justice
indépendante
nous ne pouvons pas accepter la mise en
oeuvre du plan de relance européen sans
aucun sens sans aucun contrôle enfin sur
le budget et l'économie européenne
le plan de relance qui finalement
consiste à endetter l'europe pour faire
des plans nationaux
qui devait être un moment hamiltonien
reste aujourd'hui un one shot alors que
nous avons parce qu'il faut reconstruire
l'ukraine parce qu'il faut réussir la
transition écologique le besoin de
ressources propres et le point de
transformer ce plan de relance
européenne n'ont pas en un plan pour une
fois mettant une démarche significative
et de long terme qui permettra à
l'europe d'avoir une économie forte et
d'être attractive je vous remercie
merci chers collègues et maintenant la
paix la tribune la dame marthe a26 draft
pour les républicains
monsieur le président madame la ministre
monsieur le président de la commission
mais chers collègues le 9 décembre
dernier le président de la république
présenté les priorités de la présidence
française de l'union européenne en
abordant la kz d'une europe plus
souverain
la stabilité et la sécurité de notre
voisinage il estimait alors qu'on ne
pouvait pas bâtir l'europe de la paix si
nous laissions les balkans occidentaux
dans la situation où ils étaient et
appelait donc à un réengagement fort de
l'union dans la région six mois plus
tard face à la nouvelle donne
géopolitique en europe cette affirmation
est plus que jamais d'actualité
mais le réengagement promis fait
toujours défaut en tant que président du
groupe d'amitié france balkans
occidentaux du sénat je ne peux que le
regretter lors du conseil européen les
27 chefs d'état et de gouvernement à
accorder le statut de pays candidat à
l'ukraine et à la moldavie face à
l'agression russe ce geste de solidarité
et d'unité européenne était nécessaire
le conseil européen a d'ores et déjà
annoncé que le chemin vers l'adhésion
sera long et a raison car la priorité
est à la fin du conflit militaire à la
reconstruction puis à la mise en oeuvre
progressive des acquis européen avant
d'envisager toute accession à l'union
européenne
mais cette nouvelle donne a totalement
bouleversé la perspective européenne des
balkans occidentaux face à ce
bouleversement quel message a été envoyé
à ses états voisins de l'union
européenne y at il eu un réengagement
comme l'avait promis le président de la
république
malheureusement la réponse européenne
fut faible tout juste l'union européenne
at elle réaffirmé à cette occasion son
attachement total à la perspective de
l'adhésion des balkans occidentaux et à
une accélération du processus
ces conclusions du conseil européen
donne l'impression que la région demeure
au milieu du gué il y apporte en urgence
à réengager clairement la dynamique
européenne des balkans occidentaux
urgence car des signes de progrès sont
envoyés par les pays des balkans
occidentaux des tensions bilatérales
s'apaisent des efforts sensibles sont
opérés pour se mettre en conformité avec
la règle européenne
ils doivent être récompensés
urgence car l' influence des pays
étrangers comme la chine la russie ou la
turquie sur la région est grandissante
vous l'avez rappelé madame la ministre
et la frustration et des tensions 6 ghz
face à l'absence de perspectives
européennes
l'accélération demandée par le conseil
européen doit se traduire concrètement
madame la ministre la france et les
institutions européennes
doivent s'engager fermement pour mettre
en musique les conclusions du conseil
européen sur les balkans occidentaux
au rang d'une europe plus souveraine il
est tout aussi essentiel d'évoquer la
question énergétique les conséquences de
la guerre en ukraine ont confirmé s'il
en était besoin le caractère
fondamentalement stratégique de
l'énergie mais qu'il s'agisse des
livraisons alternative de gaz de pétrole
liquéfié des achats communs de gaz ou de
la gestion des stocks stratégiques
les réponses communes élaboré pendant la
présidence française apparaissent aussi
ambitieuse dans leur principe que
fragile dans leur mise en oeuvre en
effet la paix fut eux n'aura pas permis
d'avancée décisive
je pense en particulier à l'organisation
du marché de l'électricité à propos
duquel le débat a été trop peu a trop
peu progressé à la dépendance
persistante à certaines matières
premières et équipements qui sont
indispensables au développement des
énergies renouvelables ou encore au rôle
du nucléaire dont la place au sein de la
taxonomie verte vient d'être confirmée
in extremis au parlement européen mais
qui fait toujours l'objet de virulentes
attaques alors qu'aucune transition
énergétique ne saurait être viable sans
l'atome la paix est furieux n'aura pas
été l'occasion de remettre le nucléaire
au centre du jeu énergétique européen
si l'europe sont donc être revenu dans
le secteur de l'énergie a davantage de
raisons force est de constater qu'il y a
là encore du chemin à parcourir madame
la ministre la france a un rôle moteur à
jouer en la matière elle doit se faire
entendre je vous remercie
4000 euros
la parole enfin et à notre collègue
guillaume chevrollier également pour le
groupe des républicains
monsieur le président madame la ministre
mes chers collègues il y a plus de six
mois la france avait souhaité faire de
l'environnement et du climat une
priorité de sa présidence du conseil de
l'union européenne
à l'heure du bilan le premier constat
qui s'impose est que notre pays a réussi
à aboutir un accord global sur le paquet
climat de remettre l'europe sur la
trajectoire de réduction de ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre de 55
% en 2030 par rapport à 1990 ce résultat
était loin d'être évident compte tenu de
la taille du paquet proposé et de son
caractère structurant et des positions
parfois très divergentes entre états
membres sur le texte le composant
sur le fond on peut par ailleurs se
satisfaire globalement des orientations
générales du conseil vous avez parlé on
a des ministres avancé majeur qui
correspondent pour beaucoup au point
d'attention que le sénat avait mis en
exergue dans sa résolution sur le paquet
climat et dans le rapport d'information
que sa commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et développement durable
avait consacré à la réforme du marché
carbone et à la mise en place du
mécanisme d'ajustement carbone aux
frontières car le sénat s'est investie
sur la pf yeux dans nos travaux nous
avions rappelé que la france devait
d'une part maintenir le niveau
d'ambition générale du projet proposé
par la commission européenne en
cohérence avec l'objectif de réduction
des émissions de 55% et nous avions
également souligné qu'elle devait
d'autre part préservé l'acceptabilité
sociale de l'ensemble du paquet cet
équilibre est globalement conservées par
l'accord trouvé au conseil notamment par
la mise en place d'un fonds social pour
le climat dont la taille est
probablement insuffisante pour
accompagner à lui seul les ménages
notamment les plus précaires et aussi
les travailleurs mais ce fonds le mérite
d'avoir résisté aux attaques des états
frugaux qui n'en voulait pas
toutefois le compromis de dernière
minute arraché par la présidence
française a été obtenue au prix de
plusieurs concessions à bessan quelque
peu l'ambition du paquet nous constatons
d'ailleurs que la copie rendue par le
parlement européen est plus ambitieuse
ses positions correspondent d'ailleurs
souvent recommandations exprimées par
notre commission sénatoriale lors de ces
travaux du printemps dernier je pense
tout d'abord au rythme d'extinction des
quotas gratuits sur le marché carbone
2035 pour la fin de ces quotas c'est ar
cela retardera d'autant l'entrée en
vigueur du mécanisme d'ajustement
carbone aux frontières que nous étions
beaucoup a appelée de nos voeux le
conseil aurait également pu aller plus
loin en intégrant à cette taxe carbone
aux frontières d'autres catégories de
biens par exemple les produits chimiques
organiques les plastiques ou l'hydrogène
comme nous l'avions proposé et comme le
propose aujourd'hui le parlement
européen
constatant également que l'accord au
conseil ne comble pas certain angle mort
comme celui des émissions du transport
aérien international qui ne sont pas
couvertes par le marché carbone mais par
un mécanisme korcia particulièrement peu
ambitieux le parlement européen s'est
aussi saisi du sujet en proposant des
temps le marché carbone aux vols
internationaux au départ de l'union
européenne
enfin on ne peut évoquer le bilan climat
de l'union européenne sans évoquer le
sujet notre dépendance énergétique
à l'heure où les centrales à charbon
réouvre partout en europe en raison du
conflit ukrainien la possibilité d'une
coupure totale du gaz russe combiné à
l'arrêt de plusieurs réacteurs
nucléaires nous font craindre le
scénario du pire pour reprendre les
propos du gouvernement français cette
crise énergétique menace très
sérieusement la compétitivité de nos
entreprises mais aussi l'ensemble de nos
compatriotes particulièrement les plus
modestes
à l'heure où les prix de l'essence de
l'électricité et du gaz ne cesse de
grimper cette crise doit nous montrer la
nécessité de développer une politique
européenne cohérente sur l'énergie à la
fois sur la production mais aussi sur la
consommation notamment la lutte contre
les passoires thermiques il ne fait plus
aucun doute que si nous voulons
atteindre nos objectifs climat il nous
faudra avant tout atteindre une
indépendance énergétique nationale et
européenne
une vraie souveraineté énergétique
pour ce faire la tâche reste importante
la treizième pf yeux n'a pas tout réglé
il reste du travail pour renforcer notre
europe
[Applaudissements]
merci chers collègues et bien entendu la
parole revient à la ministre de l'europe
et des affaires étrangères
monsieur le président mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
je vous remercie de vos interventions de
vos commentaires
l'appréciation est question j'ai entendu
quelques compliments je vais commencer
par répondre de façon positive je suis
en particulier très sensible
remerciements du président malhuret et
du sénateur lemoine et je veux voulait
retourner les charges en batiste parce
que vous avez directement contribué au
succès de la pf yeux comme ministre
déléguée chargée notamment de la
francophonie et des petites et moyennes
entreprises incitent du commerce
extérieur dans vos anciennes fonctions
que vous venez à peine de quitter vous
avez donc fait l'essentiel de la
présidence française du conseil de
l'union européenne
vous l'avez dit l'union entre entrepris
de reprendre le contrôle une expression
que j'ai entendu dans une exception bien
différente jusqu'à quelques semaines de
l'autre côté de la manche et si nous
faisons nôtre cette expression cette
façon plus positive donc je le fais
volontiers mienne en l'appliquant à
l'union européenne
c'est par l'europe que nous continuerons
demain à peser dans le monde que nous
pourrons pleinement protéger nos
concitoyens
définir des standards
définir de choix énergétiques
alimentaires industriels
numérique il ya derrière tout ça une
véritable réhabilitation de la politique
industrielle et de la politique
économique européenne et je vous
remercie cher jean baptiste d'avoir
porté ce combat dans vos anciennes
fonctions
plusieurs d'entre vous et notamment les
sénateurs fernique kern la sénatrice de
sidrac ainsi que le président rapin ont
évoqué à juste titre la hausse des prix
de l'énergie
comme vous le savez le gouvernement a
mis en place ici en france un bouclier
tarifaire qui gèle les tarifs
réglementés
du gaz naturel
et qui sera prolongé cela a été annoncé
jusqu'à la fin de l'année
la coordination et la solidarité des
partenaires européens à l'échelon
européen maintenant seront déterminantes
pour nous permettre de nous préparer au
mieux à l'hiver prochain le gouvernement
y veillera à la commission reviendra
vernon dès le 20 juillet dès le 20
juillet avec un plan de réduction de la
demande d'énergie là encore il sera
crucial de réagir en européens ceux des
der la commission a d'ores et déjà
adopté une boîte à outils pour autoriser
les aides d'état visant à soutenir les
consommateurs et les entreprises nous
poursuivrons nos efforts
j'ai aussi entendu
après des commentaires constructifs et
quelques compliments
quelques regrets s'exprimer et je dois
également y revenir nous serions une
europe passive ou une puissance passive
monsieur le sénateur laurent
si vous ne me croyez pas lorsque
j'affirme que cette présidence a été une
réussite écouter les autres européens
tous les pays européens tous les pays
européens on dit au contraire que la
présidence avait été active et avait
permis une présidence française du
conseil de l'union européenne comme il
convient de dire en effet réussi et tous
les gouvernements ça veut dire monsieur
le sénateur les gouvernements de droite
de gauche ou du centre tous nous
félicitent d'avoir fait progresser
l'europe dans une période au demeurant
particulièrement difficile est même
dramatique de l'avoir rendue plus forte
et plus unie
certains d'entre vous mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
ont estimé que nous aurions manqué
d'ambition sur la transition écologique
la vérité c'est que nous avons marqué au
contraire un record d'ambition et de
rapidité avec le consensus sur le paquet
climat
écoutez là aussi
le vice président de la commission
européenne en charge de ces questions
frans timmermans qui a félicité la pf
yeux en disant même je crois le site est
exactement qu'il aurait préféré en toc
socialiste ne pas avoir à le faire et
pourtant il l'a fait
sur le plan social nous aurions obtenu
des avancées en trompe l'oeil c'est
inexact
si les avancées obtenues étaient si
symbolique que vous semblez parfois le
penser les discussions n'auraient pas
fait l'objet d'années et d'années de
négociations d'année d'années de blocage
j'ai cité que parfois ces textes
attendait depuis dix ans voire 15 ans
nous sommes parvenus à convaincre nous
sommes parvenus à faire le consensus
européen sur ses avancées et c'est une
bonne chose donc je crois que nous
devrions nous féliciter de ce qui a été
fait et nous retrouver là dessus
reconnaître la réalité des faits
d'autres parmi vous ont évoqué l'état de
droit
il n'est pas possible de dire que la
présidence française ne se serait pas
battu suffisamment pour que nos
partenaires certains de nos états
membres respectent l'état de droit nous
avons mené le combat contre les
régressions démocratiques
qui apparaissent c'est vrai au sein même
de notre union c'est un combat juridique
c'est un combat politique et nous le
mènerons d'ailleurs autant qu'il le
faudra j'ai bien entendu vos déceptions
monsieur le sénateur mari mais la vérité
c'est que l'état de droit a été un fil
conducteur tout au long de ce semestre
en mettant à l'ordre du jour notamment
la situation de l'état de droit en gris
en pologne je reviendrai sur eux ce
dernier pays pour donner quelques
précisions en étant la présidence qui a
vu l'activation du mécanisme sur la
conditionnalité relative tu as droit
cela a été fait en adoptant des
conclusions sur la protection des
journalistes
en finalisant un accord au conseil sur
le financement et sur le statut des
partis politiques européens en soutenant
une révision de la charte des droits
fondamentaux pour défendre le droit à
l'avortement vous m'avez entendu rappelé
la proposition du président de la
république reprise désormais par le
parlement européen nous n'avons donc
évité aucun débat nous nous sommes
enfermés dans aucun confort nous l'avons
accepté aucune compromission sous
prétexte de faire avancer notre agenda
législatif alors je reviens sur la
situation en pologne cela fait plusieurs
années maintenant que la situation de
l'état de droit en pologne il suivi avec
une attention soutenue par l'union
européenne et en particulier par la
france avec au coeur de nos
préoccupations
le constat de défaillances structurelles
notamment celle qui compromette
l'indépendance de la justice
à l'issue de longs échanges et d'une
suspension du plan national de reprise
et de résilience rappelle le pnr
bruxelles
des engagements de la part de la pologne
ont été obtenu des engagements qui
seront vérifiées contrôler et c'est
ainsi que si la commission a donné dans
le principe son feu vert au plan
national de reprise et de résilience
polonais le 1er juin le 1er juillet la
présidente de la commission madame von
der leyen indiqué que les progrès
réellement effectués étaient
insuffisants pour permettre d'aller de
l'avant est donc insuffisant pour
débloquer le premier paiement au titre
du pnr donc paiement qui n'a pas eu lieu
pour un problème ayant trait à ces
questions de justice qui sont vraiment
au coeur des difficultés de l'état de
droit en pologne la loi ne garantissant
pas l'exclusion de toutes poursuites
disciplinaires contre un juge qui aurait
interrogé le niveau d'indépendance d'un
autre juge le dialogue se poursuivra au
sein du conseil bien sûr mais aussi dans
le cadre de cette procédure que je
rappelais fondée sur l'article 7 du
traité sur l'union européenne que nous
avons mises en oeuvre et soyez assurés
que nous serons vigilants
mais c'est le président rapin nous
aurions subi un revers avec la démission
du directeur français de frontex quelles
que soient les qualités de monsieur
l'égérie permettez moi de dire qu'il ne
faut pas mélanger deux choses il ya une
situation individuelle
que je n'ai pas à commenter au demeurant
puisque elle fait l'objet d'une enquête
enquête qui toujours en cours et qui a
conduit notre compatriote à devoir
présenter sa démission et puis d'autre
part il a le renforcement de l'agencé
frontex un renforcement qui est engagée
depuis des années comme la france a
toujours et depuis longtemps plaidé en
ce sens et qui n'est pas facile parce
qu'en effet il ya beaucoup à faire pour
renforcer la maîtrise des frontières
extérieures de l'union je suis fier au
contraire que sous notre présidence les
réformes et été accéléré s'agissant du
recrutement de corps permanent de
garde-frontières et de garde-côtes c'est
fait de l'amélioration des procédures de
signalement d'incident grave c'est fait
ou encore de la montée en puissance en
matière de retour vers les pays
d'origine en appui aux états membres
la réforme du pacte de stabilité de
croissance air également été évoquée par
plusieurs d'entre vous mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs
je peux vous indiquer que la commission
européenne fera prochainement des
propositions ce n'est pas un débat qui a
été mis de côté propositions sur la base
des orientations qu'elle avait décidé
préalablement au sommet de versailles du
mois de mars et professions qui repose
sur plusieurs principes auxquels nous
souscrivons
d'abord nous avons besoin d'une
politique économique politique
économique coordonnée pour contrer les
effets de la guerre en ukraine conforter
la stratégie de relance adopté par
l'union en juillet 2020 et d'étendre ses
goulets d'étranglement qui font monter
les prix notamment les prix de l'énergie
cette fonction de stabilisation de la
commission la promeut d'ores et déjà en
étant la clause dérogatoire général du
pacte de stabilité et de croissance
jusqu à 2023 nous sommes donc toujours
sous l'emprise de ces circonstances
exceptionnelles qui ont permis à la
commission de d'étendre cette contrainte
ensuite il faudra élaborer une
trajectoire intelligente de
désendettement compatible avec
l'investissement dans la double
transition numérique et climatique et
pour cela il sera très important de
tenir compte des situations des choix de
chaque pays chaque état membre à
l'instar de ce mécanisme d'appropriation
cas permis l'élaboration des plans
nationaux de relance et de résilience
donc nous souhaitons nous inscrire dans
une approche après l'urgence et à
presser flexibilité qui ont été étendus
jusqu à 2023 nous inscrire dans une
approche de moyen terme qui donne à
chacun la lisibilité la prévisibilité
nécessaire
l'appartenance à telle était la grande
absence de notre présidence sur le
sénateur rappelle monsieur le président
j'ai entendu vos regrets et je vous
remercie de cette question parce que
c'est un mot clé qui est au coeur du
triptyque car vole une autre présidence
ça va de pair d'ailleurs avec la volonté
de la france de bâtir une europe plus
souveraine
pourtant permettez moi de dire que les
regrets que vous avez exprimées sont
presque paradoxaux au moment au
plusieurs peuples l'ukranien mal devient
géorgiens ont exprimé l'aspiration
extrêmement forte qui est la leur
d'intégrer l'union européenne donc que
le sentiment d'appartenance
ne soit pas qu'à l'extérieur de l'union
européenne mais également à l'intérieur
c'est ce que nous devons encourager
c'est ce que nous avons voulu faire
conscients que nous sommes que l'europe
reste trop souvent une
entité lointaines à tort d'ailleurs mais
ce qu'il faut changer vous avez raison
c'est que nous devons conquérir les
coeurs et les esprits plus encore que
nous le faisons cette est l'un des axes
de notre présidence par les débats
citoyens qui ont été voulues par elle
est menée pendant un an
l'appartenance c'est d'abord ressentir
la force et la singularité de notre
modèle de nos valeurs de nos convictions
c'est de la démocratie de l'état de
droit dont je parlais et des droits
fondamentaux
donc l extérieur le cren nos appels à
l'intérieur nous devons encourager le
sentiment d'appropriation européen je
crois tout de même vous résumer que au
cours de ce semestre
face à la guerre en ukraine face à la
gare en ukraine le sentiment
d'appartenance de tous les européens
s'est accru et non pas aurait diminué
pour poursuivre sur quelques
interventions et questions qui ont été
faites le sénateur laurent je veux
répondre à votre question sur l'accord
entre l'union européenne et la
nouvelle-zélande
ce n'est pas un accord mixte c'est un
accord signé par l'union européenne dans
le cadre de ses compétences donc au sens
des institutions européennes ce qui
signifie que c'est donc au parlement
européen de se prononcer et il le fera
mais ce que je veux dire sur le fond
également c'est que c'est un bon
d'accord c'est le plus ambitieux en
matière de développement durable que
l'union européenne ait jamais conclues
sur le modèle qui nous fait désormais
envisager les accords de nouvelle
génération comme intégrant des clauses
environnementales et sociales et ça
n'était pas le cas précédemment pour les
accords commerciaux il protège nos
filières agricoles sensible et 202 sans
indication géographique
et le gouvernement s'engage bien sûr à
venir vous présentez des enjeux de cet
accord j'en prends l'engagement
sur la ruralité et plus largement
l'attention donnée à la politique
agricole madame la sénatrice guillotin
vous étiez interroger notre action était
marqué là encore par la guerre en
ukraine c'est inévitable c'est une
réalité qui s'est imposé à tous elle a
permis de conforter trois objectifs
cardinaux je parlerai dans un second
temps de la pac
produire parce qu'alors que les pays du
sud sont exposés à l'insécurité
alimentaire dont la russie porte
l'unique responsabilité par son blocus
par la guerre qu'ils mènent par les
exactions qu'elles continuent de
perpétré notre continent doit plus que
jamais être un continent de production
et même d'exportation deuxièmement
réduire nos dépendances en levant en
matière agricole nous dépendons trop
souvent des intrants qui viennent
d'ailleurs par exemple nous dépendions
des intrants de russie et de biélorussie
c'est vrai pour les engrais phosphorer
donc nous devons reconquérir là aussi
notre autonomie stratégique et
troisièmement contribuer à la lutte
contre le réchauffement est la
préservation de nos écosystèmes et à la
protection de la diversité ça reste un
impératif de long terme mais qui
requiert des actions dès maintenant ces
trois objectifs ne sont pas
incompatibles les uns avec les autres
bien évidemment pour ce qui concerne la
pac
chacun le sait le 23 mars donc moins
d'un mois ou un mois dix ans après le
déclenchement de l'invasion en ukraine
la commission a autorisé la mise en
culture
de jachères pour libérer de nouvelles
capacités de production
c'est un pas sans doute faut-il
l'encourager et c'est la guerre devait
s'installer dans la durée réfléchir à de
nouvelles évolutions mais nous avons
voulu tout de suite
permettre d'accroître les capacités de
production européenne nous devons
parallèlement parce que le marché des
céréales et les marchés alimentaires
d'une façon plus générale ce sont des
marchés mondiaux veillez à maintenir nos
marchés ouverts c'est ce que nous avons
fait c'est ce que nous avons fait en
agissant à l'om c'est le dernier conseil
ministériel de l'osce et le 12 juin a
permis d'interdire les restrictions à
l'exportation pour déjà le programme
alimentaire mondial nous agissons aussi
au sein du fida et en dotant le pam de
moyens supplémentaires un dernier mot
ces trois objectifs
de production réduction des dépendances
et d'affirmation agro écologiques nous
pourrons aller ensemble que si nous
protégeons nos marchés contre des
productions qui n'aurait pas les mêmes
niveaux d'exigence sociale et
environnementale etc cela les fameuses
clauses miroirs sur lesquels la
commission a marqué sa disponibilité à
avancer nous en sommes au début je vous
le concède mais nous avons souhaité que
notre présidence pose ce principe des
clauses miroir monsieur le sénateur
cadec parce que la réciprocité des
normes est essentiel c'est un enjeu
d'efficacité pour nos propres règles
elles permettent d'assurer que les
efforts que l'on demande à nos
producteurs ne se traduisent pas pour
eux par une perte de compétitivité
croyez-moi nous suivrons de près ce
dossier et les propositions de la
commission
j'espère avoir répondu mesdames les
sénatrices messieurs les sénateurs à la
plupart de vos observations
pour résumer croyez bien que certains
ont été votés la modestie est nécessaire
à nos fonctions je dirais même
l'humilité donc je ne tomberai
certainement pas dans l'autosatisfaction
monsieur le président rapin mais ce
sénateur cadec en laissant penser que
rien n'aurait été fait avant nous et que
nous avons tout fait on si moi ça n'est
pas cela une présidence une présence
suppose de l'humilité de la persévérance
une vision nous prenons l'europe tels
que on nous l'a confie et nous la
rendons à ceux qui nous suivent en
meilleur état si possible c'est ce que
nous avons fait donc je veux souligner
le travail de tous ceux qui nous ont
précédés je le fais volontiers comme de
tous ceux qui vont nous suivre je
rappelle aussi que
tout ce travail qui a été accompli salué
partout en europe il a été possible
grâce à votre aide grâce à l'impulsion
du président de la république grâce au
soutien de forces vives grâce au soutien
aussi de nos citoyens et je m'aperçois
que ce sénateur mari madame massiat
tribute à que j'ai oublié de vous
répondre sur un point particulier
important puisque c'est là aussi un des
longs combats de la france la
transposition de l'accord de principe
trouvé l ocde sur la taxation du
numérique n'a pas pu encore aboutir n'a
pas pu aboutir sous notre présidence va
vu que l' ocde vient de se donner elle
même un peu plus de temps mais le débat
que vous avez évoquées et dans lequel
le président de la république vous a
promis que nous n'aurions pas de tabou
le débat sur la réforme du
fonctionnement de l'union européenne
peut-être sur la sortie l'unanimité il
devra porter sur la politique étrangère
s'il n'y a pas de tabou mais devra aussi
porter sur la fiscalité et là ce sont
peut-être des partenaires qui sont plus
interrogatifs que nous pour notre part
nous souhaitons qu'ils portent sur la
fiscalité soyez assurés il y aura donc
plein d'autres chantiers je fais plein
de confiance à la présidence tchèque et
à celle au pluriel qui suivront pour
continuer la construction d'une europe
plus souveraine plus unis et qui
répondent aux attentes de nos peuples je
vous remercie
merci madame la ministre et je vais
suspendre la séance pour quelques
instants au permettre le passage ou
prochain point à l'ordre du jour qui est
la proposition de loi sur les contenus
terroristes